[Musique]
Lionel Zinsou bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
écoutez j'ai 68 ans je suis français et
béninois
et j'ai fait dans ma carrière des choses
un peu singulières j'ai commencé comme
un universitaire j'ai été étudiant en
France un peu en Angleterre
nord-malien d'ailleurs j'ai ensuite
enseigné à l'École normale supérieure de
la rue j'y suis rentré en historien j'en
suis sorti en agrégé de d'économie
j'ai enseigné avec beaucoup de plaisir
d'ailleurs tout ce que j'ai fait
professionnellement mais toujours
rempli de bonheur singulièrement mais
j'ai voulu faire une expérience
d'entreprise j'ai donc pris un congé
sabbatique de l'université
j'étais donc à l'époque à l'École
normale supérieure chargée de
transformer des mathématiciens des
philosophes
en économiste en sociologue en juriste
les tournées un peu vers les sciences
sociales je suis dit il faut aller dans
une entreprise c'est nécessaire quand on
enseigne de l'économie une entreprise
m'a fait une proposition c'était Danone
mais au lieu de rester les deux années
sabbatiques que j'avais négocié avec
l'Éducation nationale j'ai passé 11 ans
et donc je ne suis pas revenu à
l'université
au bout d'un certain temps chez Danone
mon patron que je respectais beaucoup
qui était Antoine ribouc qui avait fait
de cette entreprise un peu différente de
toutes les autres
et partir à la retraite mais c'est grand
âge ça m'a libéré et je suis allé dans
une banque pour créer un groupe
s'occupant de conseiller toutes les
entreprises de bien de consommation qui
ressemblait à Danone c'est donc cette
banque c'était Rothschild et compagnie
c'était un moment où jeed avait été
nationalisé et venait de récupérer
dans une privatisation venait de
récupérer son nom sa marque et quelques
années auparavant donc ils avaient
redémarré dans le conseil c'est une
banque où je n'ai jamais vu d'argent
c'est pas une banque qui empruntait de
l'argent à des clients pour en prêter à
d'autres c'est une banque qui faisait du
conseil de l'intermédiation qui sur des
transactions ou vendaient des
entreprises où on les aidait à grandir
ou en structurelle leur capital etc donc
dans un métier vraiment de conseil c'est
une mort qui n'était pas vraiment un
métier d'argent sauf que il y avait
toujours une dimension économique et
financière pour ça qu'on intervenait et
j'ai fait ça encore 11 ans
c'était intéressant d'ailleurs parce que
c'était pas tellement respecté par les
banquiers de travailler sur du bien de
consommation au fond c'est les histoires
de yogourt de petits pois de parfum de
pharmacie de temps en temps c'est moins
chic que de conseiller sur les
technologies sur les télécommunications
sur les fusions entre les banques donc
on a commencé petit et regardez avec un
certain dédain par les grands
professionnels ce qui est une position
très confortable au bout de 11 ans
c'était le premier groupe et ça allait
rester dans cette banque qui est dans
les 10 premières banques mondiales
d'affaires c'était devenu le premier
groupe sectoriel ce qui est normal
d'ailleurs parce que tout ce qui touche
à la consommation des ménages du monde
il y a 8 milliards de clients et c'est
évidemment avec l'agroalimentaire au
centre la première industrie du monde
donc peut-être c'est logique qu'on est
un peu de travail et on a donc été
regardé avec une considération
pas malveillante mais au fond tout de
même un peu lointaine et puis on fait on
a quand même réussi à faire notre métier
et puis
au bout de ses 11 ans là pendant 7 ans
j'ai dirigé un fond de capital
investissement donc des gens qui eux se
tournent vers des investisseurs
rassemble quelques centaines de millions
ou quelques milliards d'euros et doivent
les placer ils ont pour ça 10 ans
5 ans où il déploie ce capital et ça
consiste à prendre des participations
aux entreprises essayer d'y créer de la
valeur de l'expansion contrairement à ce
que les gens croient essayer d'y créer
du plus d'emplois possible et avec ces
entreprises là au fond les conduire les
accompagner les aider dans leur façon
très active en fait dans leur gestion et
puis le passé les 5 à 7 années ça peut
durer 12 ans
qui suivent à et bien à désinvestir et
la mesure du succès c'est pouvoir créer
de la valeur et qu'il y ait des
plus-values métier que beaucoup de gens
n'aiment guère métier a assez fort
rendement du capital
qui rapporte en général aux
investisseurs
plutôt des rendements font des profits à
deux chiffres au sens où c'est mieux que
la
finance pardon qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait après la finance
alors donc j'ai fait de la finance
pendant quand même une vingtaine
d'années et puis au bout de mon mandat
j'ai été rattrapé par un devoir civique
c'est à dire que dans mon pays d'origine
celui de mon père le Bénin le président
de la République m'a dit il était en fin
de mandat de rester un an
tu m'as opposé pendant des années que tu
ne pouvais pas venir au gouvernement tu
pouvais pas rentrer au pays parce que ça
aurait déséquilibré le fond que tu
dirais ou parce que tu venais de rentrer
au comité exécutif de la banque
Rothschild mais je viens de dire dans le
journal que ton mandat était terminé et
donc tu es obligé de venir et donc tu
viens la semaine prochaine comme premier
ministre et ton job c'est simple c'est
on termine le plus de choses possible on
a entrepris beaucoup de choses
c'est assez complexe de d'arriver à au
bout des projets simulés dans les pays
africains dans les pays en développement
en général on toujours un temps fou à
faire bouger les lignes donc là on a une
dernière année et avec une équipe
rassemblée une équipe certains
continuent à travailler aujourd'hui avec
moi je suis très très heureux avec une
équipe on a essayé de finir le plus de
choses possibles au service de ce pays
le Béda et puis voilà et puis alors je
me sentais vraiment pas très politicien
encore que il faut le dire assez vite
parce que dans ma famille notre oncle
enfin mon oncle le chef de notre famille
dans un pays qui s'appelait à l'époque
le Dahomey qui était indépendant en 1960
en 1968 mon nom notre chef de famille
est devenu président de la République
auparavant il avait été ministre
avant
l'indépendance il avait été un élu il
avait terminé 1954 quand je suis né le
benjamin du Sénat il avait été élu pour
la première fois de sa vie à 26 ans il
était devenu président de la République
à 5 ans donc on ne peut pas dire que
j'ignorais tout de la politique au Bénin
en réalité toutes mes familles avaient
été engagée
c'est au point d'ailleurs où le jour où
j'ai annoncé ma mère voilà le président
de la République me propose de Premier
ministre
elle m'a dit écoute sois gentil ton père
tes oncles innover ça que ça toute leur
vie oui ils étaient médecins oui mon
père enseignait il est toujours vivant
il lance la battant à grande âge il
enseignait la médecine était chirurgien
il avait beaucoup de travail mais enfin
grosso modo quand même ce qu'il
passionnait dans la vie c'était la
politique elle me dit écoute maintenant
on a assez donné attends que je sois
morte m'a fait un choc le lendemain
matin elle m'a dit tu oublies tout ce
que j'ai dit
je t'autorise à devenir Premier ministre
j'avais pas grand monde dans la famille
qui était partisans
je dis il est encore parce que on ne
quitte jamais cette fonction et il
aimait rentrer à l'Académie de chirurgie
il y a 3 ans à 93 ans si vous voulez
donc il était
chirurgien mais il était professeur de
gynécologie et d'obstétrique et il avait
été en France mais il avait été à Dakar
longtemps il avait été à Libreville
voilà il était professeur des facultés
françaises le Bénin est réputé pour
produire beaucoup d'agrégés de beaucoup
de choses surtout des agrégés de
médecine et désagrégés de droit pas tant
que ça des engagés de sciences
économiques pour dire la vérité mais on
aurait pu être le quartier latin de
l'Afrique et vous trouvez des médecins
béninois partout partout en Afrique
président Sarkozy se moquait un peu de
nous en disant il y a plus de médecins
béninois dans la région parisienne qu'au
Bénin
ça c'est un drame un drame de l'Afrique
c'est que elle continue en fait d'être
au fond
une mine de talent qu'on continue de
faire venir alors qu'il y a des
politiques et des discours
de la migration
qui au fond déstabilise en réalité on
continue aujourd'hui c'est même plus
fort que jamais à importer des
compétences africaines et donc en
démunir l'Afrique et c'est très frappant
pour les médecins la moitié de la
promotion de notre école paramédicale du
nord du Bénin par à coup par directement
en Europe et presque autant de notre
faculté à abomeiquer la vie au sud à
côté de la capitale économique Cotonou
près de la moitié de la Faculté de
médecine par en Europe
c'est vrai des ingénieurs
des salaires c'est à cause que la France
s'y fait le pénurie mondial d'un certain
nombre de choses
c'est à cause de quoi c'est par manque
de patriotisme c'est par manque de quoi
il y a une pénurie mondiale d'un certain
nombre de compétences
on estime qu'il doit manquer près de 20
millions
de médecins dans le monde donc les
problèmes de la démographie
médicale française les déserts médicaux
etc
c'est pas un phénomène français un
phénomène mondial
partir de là il est vrai que vous vous
commencez votre carrière de médecin
hospitalier au Bénin et vous allez
gagner probablement quelque chose comme
8 à 10 fois moins
que ce que vous allez gagner si vous
partez dans un pays européen qui pas les
mêmes appareils pas les mêmes techniques
pas les mêmes types de formation oui
enfin ça il faut le dire assez vite si
vous voulez
l'expérience professionnelle
en Afrique c'est que par exemple les
étudiants en médecine sont très très
vite aux cheveux du malade le niveau de
formation est excellent
pas différents significativement des
programmes
européens oui il y a beaucoup moins
d'équipements ça c'est vrai il y a une
véritable misère de l'hôpital public
même si la prise de conscience pendant
la pandémie en 2020
du fait du covid fait que
un effort assez important est en train
de se mobiliser de se concrétiser en
Afrique pour améliorer les systèmes de
santé publique mais qu'il s'agisse du
privé ou du public on a moins de moyens
mais c'est une médecine en réalité d'une
très très grande qualité qui a souvent
des liens avec les pastoriens c'est non
c'est d'une très grande qualité avec des
moyens véritablement
misérables on va revenir sur l'Afrique
après on va commencer par la finance
comment vous pourriez définir la morale
dans la finance est-ce qu'il y a une
morale dans la finance
s'amusant parce que
la morale ou la finance votre question
parce que c'est une question que mes
parents m'ont opposé
ma mère était infirmière générale à
l'Assistance publique hôpitaux de Paris
mon père était médecin hospitalier et
professeur de faculté de médecine quand
j'ai dit en terminale je vais pas faire
de médecine c'est des terribles parce
que m'a dit mais qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire qui éthiquement aurait la même
nécessité et la même légitimité c'est
pas possible je ne peux pas faire ça
et alors on a passé enfin j'aurais dit
il y a une seule spécialité qui
m'intéresse c'est la psychiatrie alors
ça ça les a câblés parce que mon père
chirurgien et que les chirurgiens les
psychiatres sont quand même à deux
extrêmes un peu de la pratique
chirurgiens des psychiatres
à la coupole je sais pas si vous savez
c'est la coupole dans une faculté de
médecine le professeur de chirurgie
opère et ses étudiants sont au-dessus et
il y a une coupole transparente un micro
et tous ces gestes sont expliqués
j'avais 10 ans je savais pas quoi faire
de moi quand il était à l'hôpital donc
souviens à l'hôpital et tu te mets et tu
regardes comment et c'est très physique
j'entendais mon père dire passez-moi le
rabot si vous voulez parce qu'il faisait
en Afrique on fait tout donc pas que de
la chirurgie liée à l'obstétrique il
faisait aussi la chirurgie générale
passez-moi la scie passez-moi bon on va
on va recoudre le malade ou bien
le malade fuient
l'anesthésie est en train de prendre fin
il va se réveiller il va nous mourir
entre les doigts ça c'était le quotidien
quand j'avais 10 ans en vacances
scolaires comme je ne savais pas quoi
faire quoi faire de je voyais très bien
combien c'était physique et ce qui
m'intéressait c'était l'aspect au
contraire
spéculatif intellectuel au fond j'étais
un élève de philosophie passionnée et je
me disais la psychiatrie la
psychédélisme l'inverse en fait de ce
côté extrêmement matériel manuel de la
chirurgie c'est ce qui m'intéresse le
plus et c'est ce qui inquiétait le plus
ne pas
psychiatrie franchement quelle question
la question c'était non mais la question
c'était
tu es obligé de faire quelque chose
d'éthique ma question votre question
c'était
il me semble à me rappeler votre
question c'est définissez la morale de
la finance et alors je leur ai dit on a
fait on a fait un pacte je vais rentrer
dans une classe préparatoire
littéraire
je voulais quand même me rapprocher
quelque chose de psychédique mais en
fait il y a quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est la finance
pourquoi parce que mon grand-père
maternel était banquier directeur de la
Banque de France et donc mon enfant
maternel c'était d'aller chez mes
grands-parents et il était directeur de
comptoir de la Banque de France et on
vous a sa carrière de comptoir en
comptoir de succursale en succursale à
Quimper à Perpignan puis augmenter en
grade à Montpellier Capital régional à
Toulouse mais c'était un banquier
central c'était la Banque de France
c'est-à-dire que je me suis fait une
représentation de la finance comme d'un
métier honorable
d'intérêt général très proche de l'État
souverain emblématique de l'État
souverain et donc j'ai une déviation par
rapport aux communs des mortels c'est de
penser que c'est un métier extrêmement
honorable et d'ailleurs honoré
et personne dans la famille ne
s'intéressait à ce qu'il faisait
sauf moi alors j'avais 13 14 ans et
quand vous êtes directeur de banque de
France un des moments phares de l'année
vous préparez les quelques pages qui
concernent votre région votre secteur
pour le rapport du gouverneur qui va les
remettre au président de la République
et donc et ben il me faisait descendre
dans le bureau et puis il me faisait
lire
commenter corriger la fraction du
rapport du gouvernement après je suis
devenu ami de plusieurs gouverneurs
notamment Jean-Claude Trichet ou du
gouverneur Villeroy de Ganot François
c'est resté pour moi un peu une mystique
donc je me disais non seulement c'est la
finance c'est morale mais c'est
fondamental pour l'économie et c'est de
la régulation de la réglementation etc
et je me disais au fond quand je suis
rentré à Louis le Grand en classe
préparatoire
si c'est dur si on apprend à travailler
trop on apprend bien enfin c'est quand
même des années intéressantes oui le
grand parce que le pacte c'était mon
père était le médecin de la présidence
de la République du Sénégal
et donc il avait dit au président
Senghor
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de cet enfant
qui ne croit pas que la seule vertu
éthique c'est de faire de la médecine
mais alors il faut qu'il aille en
hypoigne à l'huile grande dans celle où
j'étais avec Georges Pompidou
et c'est la hK2 donc je suis rentré en
H2 alors pour rentrer à l'huile de
passeport j'avais été lors du concours
général de composition française donc je
pouvais rentrer dans la canne dans
l'hypokaïne que je souhaitais donc je
suis rentré là en hK2 parce que c'était
celle du président Senghor et de son ami
Georges Pompidou or qu'est-ce qui avait
fait Georges Pompidou
après l'école normale supérieure après
avoir été majeur de l'agrégation de
lettres classique il avait été le [__]
l'écrivain public le [__] ça du général
de Gaulle juste après
au moment de où il s'installe à l'hôtel
de briette en partir de 1944 et puis
quand le général de Gaulle se retire il
était rentré dans une banque la banque
Rothschild
et puis général de Gaulle revenu aux
affaires l'avait appelé à la direction
du cabinet à l'Elysée
et puis le temps de mettre en place la
Cinquième République il est retourné
comme directeur général de la banque
Rothschild jusqu'à ce que le président
de la République lui demande de venir
Premier ministre après le renversement
par la population nationale par une
motion de censure de Michel Debré
Premier ministre de la 5e République
c'est l'époque Bernard a raison oui
c'est tout à fait le moment où Bernard
Lambert rentre comme un des grands
conseillers sur la politique économique
industrielle du président Pompidou c'est
des grandes années
tout se joue sur les télécommunications
le nucléaire grandes aînés industrielles
c'est la fin glorieuse des trentes
glorieuses bon et puis il avait quitté
en 1968 et au fond revenu en président
de la République en 1969 donc dans son
hypokhâgne puis dans sa Cagne je me
disais ah ben le parcours idéal ce
serait quand même de faire exactement la
quelque chose et donc je me suis dit
faudra rentrer d'abord c'est une bonne
comment dire intellectuellement c'est
très intéressant puisque c'est un art de
du pastiche c'est très intéressant
d'être le [__] d'un homme politique
quand on dit c'est le [__] de
ça pour que vous ne l'aimiez pas c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle
alors après les séries américaines
appellent ça des speechrighters
que sortir de l'école normale j'ai
enseigné à l'université en économie et
qu'elle professeur de l'École normale
qui s'appelait Laurent Fabius
un jour s'est aperçu que je faisais des
travaux de sur l'économie industrielle
qu'il était ministre de l'Industrie que
j'étais son étudiant
et qu'au fond je pouvais lui servir
d'agréger sachantée
définition que Gérald De Gaulle avait
donné un de ses collaborateurs monsieur
Bugeon de l'État trouvez moi
dans cette maison de l'étang je vais
retrouver qui c'était trouvez-moi un
agrégé sachant que
au fond et je suis devenu specher je me
suis dit là ça s'engage bien parce que
si vous voulez pas que je suis devenu
maigre
je vous comprends
et donc je suis devenu chargé de mission
chargée de l'expression du ministre de
l'Industrie qui est devenu premier
ministre donc j'ai fait le même métier à
Matignon qui est une maison intéressante
et qui permet de voir beaucoup plus de
sujets puisque c'est interministériel
par nature avec un premier ministre que
j'estimais comme mon professeur qui
avait été mon prof à l'École normale et
qui restait un ami très fidèlement et
donc si bon c'est bien d'enclenché donc
au fond j'ai été normalisé parce que je
sortais d'un Pompidou
maintenant il va falloir que je fasse
assez vite de la finance
et même si j'ai fait un crochet chez
Danone dans l'industrie le jour de
décembre 1995 Édouard de Rothschild
m'invite à déjeuner me dit on a
travaillé pas mal ensemble quand tu
t'occupes des acquisitions de Danone
et on te trouve des qualités de
banquiers est-ce que tu pourrais
considérer
de rentrer à la banque Rothschild il
pensait que ça allait prendre 6 mois de
négociation j'ai répondu oui
bah c'est un peu rapide quand même dis
non non parce que dans mon esprit c'est
très clair en fait le chemin était tracé
donc oui oui tout à fait moi ça me
convient tout à fait je suis tout à fait
des années que j'y pense j'ai négocié le
salaire tout de suite ou pas du tout ça
ce négocie pas à ce moment là
c'est amusant votre question
c'est très pertinent évidemment tu sais
pas
faire de la banque d'affaires même si tu
étais directeur du développement chargé
des fusions acquisition chez Danone à un
moment donné
donc ce qu'on pourrait faire c'était
recruter comme gérant
qui n'est pas le gras le plus élevé mais
te payer tout de suite comme associé
gérant je te rassure parce que tu
membres du comité exécutif d'une
multination et j'ai dit à Édouard non en
fait on va faire l'inverse en fait vous
allez me nommer tout de suite à ce sujet
et puis vous allez me payer comme gérant
parce que je m'en fiche
parce que je souhaite c'est être associé
Jean qui est
le garde le plus le plus élevé et le
négociation était terminé donc ils ont
pris ils ont pris la nomenclature des
salaires et les gérants c'est un grade
de salariés les associés gérants c'est
un peu une profession libérale c'est la
prime
c'est à dire que au fond vous devez être
analyste et puis vous vous montez
jusqu'à directeur et gérant et si vous
êtes dans une grille de salaire après
vous êtes plutôt intéressé aux résultats
d'ensemble de la banque donc associé est
une position
plus plus enviable dans les bonnes
conjonctures qui motive plus dangereuses
dans les dans les moments un peu
compliqués de la conjoncture quand le
marché s'effondre donc vous êtes c'est
variable c'était combien chez routine à
écouter ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que c'est pour moi c'était un tout petit
peu indifférent parce que chez Danone
Antoine Ribou m'avait dit combien vous
gagnez l'université et là j'avais dit X
et c'est pas beaucoup de mettre
assistant à l'université mais je fais un
peu de consultation comme les
enseignants d'économie donc c'est un peu
plus que un professeur d'économie m'a
dit bon écoutez probablement vous avez
pas réussi probablement va vous virer
dans deux ans vous allez retourner à
l'université là vous êtes en congé
sabbatique donc faut pas qu'on dérange
vos habitudes
on va vous laisser votre salaire
là je crois qu'ils ont fait une économie
que de moitié quelque chose comme ça et
après ils m'ont promu très vite en fait
ils m'ont promu très vite parce qu'il
avait des sujets de succession il
fallait il atteigna grand âge il fallait
qu'il y ait une nouvelle génération
m'ont promis assez vite tous les deux
ans mais chaque fois il me recevait en
me disant la promotion doit vous être
très satisfaisante donc c'est peut-être
pas la peine de vous augmenter
la meilleure année c'était combien avant
en pot
non mais si vous voulez j'ai gagné à la
fin chez Danone quelque chose qui me
satisfaisait parce que ça avait quand
même être dix fois ce que j'aurais gagné
si j'étais resté professeur des
universités donc à la fin des fins il a
fini par meugmenter mais j'avais 10 000
personnes ça se dit pas responsabilité
non parce que j'ai oublié le chiffre n'a
vraiment je vous assure j'ai quitté
quand même en 896 si vous voulez donc
mais je rappelle je me rappelle d'une
certaine satisfaction parce que
parce que c'était quand même
sensiblement plus que ce que j'aurais
gagné dans la fonction publique et
ensuite je suis reparti à peu près du
même niveau justement du comité exécutif
d'une multinationale donc je suis parti
à peu près au même niveau chez
Rothschild et puis après ça dépend des
années
il y a sûrement un moment où ça atteint
ça au sommet du cycle mais c'était pas
du salaire c'était avec la quote pas
partage du profit de la banque
la morale dans la finance
donc si vous voulez le problème c'est
que on a posé la question éthique tu
veux vraiment pas faire de la médecine
tu veux vraiment faire de la finance
mais j'ai résolu mon problème mythique
parce que de la finance vous connaissait
que le métier de banquier central bien
sûr les banquiers centraux c'est un
métier très très heureux parce que ils
ont vraiment l'impression de sauvegarder
la planète tous les jours d'assurer la
stabilité du système financier ils sont
beaucoup beaucoup moins payés que les
banquiers commerciaux s'ils appellent
les banquiers primaires non pas du tout
que au sens qui ne serait pas
sophistiqué mais tout ce qu'on appelle
les banques primaires les banques
centrales sont tout de suite des banques
primaires donc ça c'est la résolu tout
de suite mon problème d'éthique ensuite
une banque d'affaires
en fait ne m'a pas posé de problèmes
d'éthique parce que
l'argent est presque et presque
immatériel invisible ce que vous essayez
de faire c'est de conseiller
des entreprises sur leur expansion sur
leur restructuration quand elles sont en
difficulté et au fond
vous ne vous n'êtes pas un commerçant
d'argent si vous voulez donc c'est ça
devient très immatériel j'étais très
surpris quand je suis allé au Bénin et
où il y a une campagne électorale et où
j'étais candidat au présidentielle et
mes adversaires
disaient mais c'est juste un petit
commerçant simplement ils vendent
l'argent et à aucun moment il se sentit
pas parce que à aucun moment je me suis
retrouvé en train de négocier du crédit
avec quiconque si vous voulez donc si
vous voulez
la question c'est
l'utilité de ce métier qui n'est pas un
métier
respecter partout c'est notamment
j'étais le collaborateur de Premier
ministre de gauche j'étais engagé à
gauche et donc les gens se demandaient
et au Bénin
il se demandait avec
violence contre moi mais est-ce qu'on
peut être un homme de gauche
et faire ce métier d'argent et je voyais
pas de quoi il parlait parce que c'est
pas un métier d'argent c'était un métier
de stratégie
et donc
voilà je vais maintenant méditer pour
mes mémoires sur mais il y avait-il un
problème éthique que j'ai pas vu pendant
30 ans
qu'elle regarde maintenant vous portez
je vous prends un exemple la crise de
2008 d'où ça vient pourquoi c'est arrivé
quel regard vous portez sur l'hyper
frequencie trading quel regard vous
portez sur des banques qui cherchent à
maximiser leur profit le plus rapidement
possible
celle qui celle qui cherche à maximiser
le plus rapidement possible
se retrouve quand même souvent
mon nombre de celles qui disparaissent
dans les crises
tout fait et puis il y a toujours l'État
pour aller derrière donc
oui les plus grandes et les plus grandes
le plus grandes sont un peu protégés
on change simplement complètement la
direction complètement les règles
protégés ou elles ont un si vous me
permettez l'expression elles ont un
flingue sur les démocraties
non mais si vous voulez Lehman qui n'est
pas une très grande banque mais qui
était quand même suffisamment grande
pour être systémique par sa faillite
septembre 2008
ça veut dire que vous avez des
entreprises qui quand elle s'effondre ne
crée de dégâts que pour leurs salariés
leurs actionnaires les partis prenantes
dans la mesure où vous êtes partout dans
le système bancaire parce que vous êtes
le client le déposant ou l'acteur qui
agit pour toutes les autres banques
parce que toutes les banques ont des
relations entre elles votre faillite va
entraîner des dizaines de faillites
d'autres banques dans le système
financier et donc vous avez des petites
banques ici elle s'effondre ne font de
mal que aux parties prenantes immédiates
et vous en avez qui sont assez grandes
pour pouvoir mettre à genoux le système
financier international et qui arrive en
septembre 2008 c'est cela c'est que
l'éman est assez grande
bersterns était trop petite mais avait
fait déjà faillite plusieurs mois
auparavant mais les mains n'était quand
même suffisamment grande pour mettre en
difficulté l'ensemble du système
bancaire mondial ça a provoqué la
nationalisation temporaire des grandes
banques américaines de la plupart des
banques britanniques et dans beaucoup
beaucoup de pays des faillits de banques
ou des nationalisations de banque parce
que on ne peut pas se passer d'avoir des
intermédiaires financiers donc c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est passé une crise
financière je suis désolé mais il va y
avoir d'autres crises financières
longtemps on disait
longtemps on disait que il y avait un
rythme d'à peu près 11 ans en 1987 vous
avez une crise financière majeure en 97
vous en avez une autre il y en a une qui
intervient en 2008 il se trouve que au
Cercle des économistes d'Aix-en-Provence
qui est une réunion intéressante au mois
de juillet des économistes français et
d'économistes internationale en 2007
on m'interroge donc en 2007 je suis à la
banque Rothschild mais on m'a invité
comme africain comme économiste africain
et mais bon maître des économistes
français
me donne un sujet à traiter qu'est-ce
que nous pays riches 2007 on est au
sommet de la conjoncture qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire pour vous autres là les
pays africains qui vous rendraient
service vous formulez ça comme ça
écoutez non mais c'était ça que ça
voulait dire et alors mon exposé a un
peu frappé parce que je leur ai dit
écoutez
vous êtes au balcon là au nord nous on
est en bas là au rez-de-chaussée vous
nous regardez d'en haut comme ça je suis
pas sûr que c'est la bonne approche
parce que si on voulait des leçons de
croissance en fait on vous les
demanderait pas à vous on demanderait
pas aux occidentaux on dirait lui
demander au chinois au vietnamien
qui eux sont experts en croissance donc
au fond on vous demande rien on vous
demande simplement de ne pas nous faire
une crise économique une crise
financière qui elle va vraiment nous
gêner c'est ça le service que vous
pouvez nous rendre le 15 juillet 2007
j'aurais dit vous savez il y a un
problème c'est que bersterns vient de
faire faillite bersters c'est la plus
petite des grandes banques
à New York malheureusement en 87 et en
les deux qui sont à la frontière entre
grandes très grande banque et petite
banque qui s'appelle berstand et Lehmann
ont fléchit on a réussi à les sauver ça
entraîner une crise financière mondiale
bershtstern a déposé son bilan en mai
il suffit d'attendre l'éman et on va
avoir une crise financière mondiale et
ben si vous aviez vous avez encore un
peu de temps si vous aviez la
gentillesse de ne pas faire ça nous
auriez déjà rendu le plus grand service
vous avez compris le mécanisme pourquoi
ils sont fait et vous observerez que
heureusement ça a été écrit en fait
parce que il y a des actes et on avait
été deux à dire ça à cette réunion de
d'Aix-en-Provence
de la Banque de France
et cette mise en et 10 ans après
à Aix j'ai rendu hommage je me suis pas
rendu hommage à moi-même je vous le
racontez à vous mais en fait je raconte
jamais à personne mais
pour me faire plaisir quand même j'ai
rendu hommage à Christian il était le
seul à dire ça en 2007 et voilà ce qui
s'est passé en 2008 c'était prévisible
parce que il y avait un mouvement de
spéculation une bulle tout à fait
dangereuse qui était d'ailleurs signalé
par certains économistes et un homme qui
a fait toutes ses carrières là-dessus
c'est Muriel robinet mais il y avait
l'attaché financier qui est un de mes de
mes professeurs à moi Jacques mistral
qui était attaché financier de France à
Washington qui envoyait une note sur
note sur le thème la façon dont on
finance le logement les fameux prêts de
ces fameux subprimes
concourir un risque très sérieux au
système bancaire américain
et et par extension et Paris Cochet
un vrai un vrai risque systémique
mondial dans le système financier
comment vous percevez bon maintenant
qu'on a posé de trois bases
les banques centrales la Fed Ben Pernon
qui a reçu le prix Nobel du mois le
commence on dit pas prix Nobel
d'économie on dit le prix de la Banque
de Suède c'est ça
d'économie un caractère mondial
la Banque centrale européenne
a inondé de liquidités on l'appelait
hélicoptère ben aussi du côté américain
comment vous percevez ça c'était une
bonne stratégie c'est pas une bonne
stratégie c'était c'était
un pansement sur une jambe de bois
c'était protégé les boomers c'était il
fallait le faire tout de suite parce que
sinon je vais être vulgaire on se vaut
très lamentablement et on repassait sur
la destruction créatrice de ce que vous
voulez comment vous percevez la
politique des banques centrales après
2008 puis après on va on va avancer avec
le Quantitative Easing on va avancer
avec tous ces mécanismes là et on va
décortiquer le le prix le prix de la
Banque de Suède
écoutez à partir de la mi-septembre 2008
on bascule dans une situation
où plus personne n'a confiance dans le
système financier on peut vite au
plafond
c'est moi qui vais vous demander
d'expliquer ce que le VIX année en fait
un indicateur de la volatilité des
marchés et le fait qu'ils peuvent d'un
jour à l'autre passer moins 10% à plus 5
sur une volatilité absolument
considérable je vous perturberai une
volatilité sur une
courbe descendante
plus c'est descend c'est ça je vais vous
perturber un peu dans ma question je
vais en mettre une à tiroir n'oubliez
pas on va parler du scandale du rebord
et de le rebord ok je vous laisse
continuer sur la politique des banques
centrales
le fait que le monde ne soit pas
effondré
sur le plan financier en paralysant
au-delà de ce qui a quand même été
réalisé c'est à dire une récession
mondiale
patient importante que ça mais enfin
quand même une récession mondiale et un
effondrement des marchés financiers des
bourses de valeurs
le fait que ça ne se soit pas effondré
dans la durée mais que la crise est
durée quelques mois seulement
à reposer sur la volonté de quelques
hommes
et parmi ces hommes là il y a vraiment
les banquiers centraux c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment Jean-Claude Trichet en
Europe c'est vraiment Ben barneke et
c'est le directeur et le secrétaire au
Trésor de la fin du mandat de George
Bush qui était auparavant le président
de Goldman Sachs qui était donc très
très familier
des marchés du système financier et
c'est le directeur de la Fédérale
réserve de New York qui était le
conseiller de Barack Obama et qui est
devenu le secrétaire au Trésor en
février puisque ça s'est passé au monde
la transition entre l'administration
bouche partir de novembre il y a
transition avec le président élu Barack
Obama c'est quelques hommes là
donc des banquiers centraux ou le
secrétaire au Trésor venant de les plus
grandes banques d'affaires du monde qui
ont réussi à prendre des mesures
extrêmement rapides avec quelques hommes
donc Gordon Brown
extrêmement compétences
de la Grande-Bretagne Premier ministre
du Royaume-Uni qui a pris des décisions
en quelques heures de nationaliser
toutes les grandes banques britanniques
pour que le système de s'effondre pas
donc c'est quelques hommes dont Nicolas
Sarkozy qui a activé un G4 et imposer la
création d'un G20
qui était en fait une organisation
technique de ministre et finances qui
est devenu une réunion de chef d'État
pour agir extrêmement vite c'est
quelques hommes qui ont sauvé le système
où les banquiers centraux viennent en
premier lieu et ils ont fait
effectivement les apports de liquidité
au risque de l'inflation mais on n'a pas
eu de période d'inflation au total et
même on a eu quelques risques de
déflation en 2008-2009 on n'est pas en
2022 on parle de 2008-2009 tout est une
question de la fermer les marchés
financiers on a réinjecté de liquidités
parce que toutes les banques étaient à
l'arrêt donc il y avait plus de moyens
de faire des transactions c'était à
l'arrêt parce que je parle sur votre
contrôle parce que elle savait pas ce
que le copain avait d'actif pourri dans
ses tiroirs c'est ça absolument et
au-delà de ça il y a eu tout un effort
de réglementation qui fait que alors
qu'en 2020 pendant le covid on était
devant une récession bien pire attendez
je vous coupe à ce moment là on a vu
quand même que les mesures mises en
place après 2008-2009 en termes de
niveau de fonds propres en termes de
conformité à des règles en termes alors
vous suggérez que pour l'instant je fais
du violon mais enfin vous les mesures
les mesure là ont plutôt stabilisé
sécuriser le système qui aurait pu
s'effondrer en 2020 donc si vous me
permettez
donc si je peux résumer avec ma propre
perception donc on a nationalisé les
pertes on l'a transformé les banques
centrales en bas de banque c'est quoi
une batte banque c'est une banque qui
rachète tout le le caca toutes les
actifs pourris
vous avez une banque dans laquelle il y
a des actifs sains et des actifs
malsains parce qu'elle a été mal gérée
parce que sa stratégie était mauvaise
parce qu'elle sait remplie de créances
douteuses parce qu'elle a suivi toutes
les bulles
spéculatives en voyant pas que ces
bulles éclatent toujours et donc au très
mauvais moment pour très cher elle a
acheté beaucoup de de d'immobilier
elles deviennent propriétaires mais elle
a financé énormément d'immobilier à des
niveaux complètement
incités absurdes etc bon donc il y a et
et il faut sauver quelque chose dans
cette banque donc on rassemble tous les
actifs malsains et au fond on va petit à
petit avec le temps les écouler à la
moitié de leur valeur on va prendre la
perte sur ça et en revanche pour qu'il
reste quelque chose d'où on puisse
repartir on met tous les crédits sains
dans une goutte banque voilà et on prend
donc une banque qui est en grande
difficulté on écarte c'est comme si
c'est comme quand on enlève une tumeur
par la chirurgie donc on enlève les
actifs dangereux et on s'occupe à perte
et c'est les actionnaires qui payent et
parfois c'est les États qui payent
en général en général les actionnaires
sont rincés assez vite et donc reste des
pertes sont souvent collectées
collectives les juniors
ne sont pas des bateaux les banques
centrales elles font en sorte que les
banques soient financées pour pouvoir
financer les entreprises et les ménages
si les banques ne sont pas n'ont pas de
ressources les entreprises s'arrêtent et
les ménages ne peuvent faire ni leurs
achats d'immobilier ni leur crédit à la
souscrire à des crédits à la
consommation peut pas s'acheter de
voiture et donc il faut qu'il y ait un
prêteur en dernier ressort et ce prêteur
il a le pouvoir de créer la monnaie et
en période de crise il crée la monnaie
et en l'occurrence il l'a fait
spectaculairement en 2008
jusque printemps 2009 et il l'a fait
spectaculairement pendant le covid
spectaculaire
heureusement il a fait parce que du coup
les banques ont été financées plus
personne n'aurait prêté l'argent aux
banques mais il a financé pas que en
2009 il y a eu quantitative
quantitative easing 1 2 3 4
et
ce sont des politiques de soutien de la
croissance si vous voulez
les les
banques centrales encore une fois sont
le prêteur en dernier ressort qui est
nécessaire
aux banques si il y a un risque de
récession ou une récession réelle et ce
que l'on appelle le
compétitive easing c'est simplement
d'ouvrir
le robinet d'ouvrir la faculté aux
banques commerciales
objets
la Barclays la Deutsche Bank
aux grandes banques commerciales de leur
donner
tes ressources financières en leur
achetant des crédits qu'elles ont fait à
des tiers et les banques centrales on a
faculté de leur donner du numéraire
contre ces
portefeuilles de crédit et certainement
quand il y a pas de risque d'inflation
mais au contraire des risques de
déflation et de récession
elles ajoutent beaucoup en fait à ce
qu'elles peuvent apporter au bord
en train d'en subir normalement c'est
quelque chose qui peut se résorber dans
l'autre sens
pardon on resserre
l'émission monétaire
les ressources des banques quand les
banques trouvent sur à la Bourse sur les
marchés financiers ou parmi les gens qui
viennent ouvrir des comptes et qu'on est
dans une période d'expansion elle trouve
tout à fait leur liquidité par elle-même
elle vous démarque et elle vous propose
des produits d'épargne et elle vous
propose d'ouvrir des comptes et moi je
suis toujours dans la même banque que
dans laquelle je suis rentré quand j'ai
eu mon premier salaire
en l'occurrence c'est générale mais qui
pourquoi parce qu'ils m'ont ils m'ont
démarché pour mon premier salaire
j'étais un étudiant salarié c'est quand
vous êtes élève professeur à l'école on
est supérieur vous êtes salarié donc
premier jour j'ai reçu une proposition
de l'agence à 200 mètres et en fait j'y
suis toujours resté donc vous vous il y
a un effort de collecter l'épargne
quand on est en période d'expansion les
banques n'ont pas besoin d'autre chose
que de l'épargne qu'apporte les
entreprises qui sont en expansion et les
ménages dont le revenu augmentent mais
quand on est dans une phase de récession
et pour que ça devienne pas une spirale
dépressive
l'État et une déflation qui paralysent
tout parce que quand vous êtes en baisse
de prix vous allez attendre que ça
baisse plus pour faire des transactions
et voyez par exemple l'immobilier
s'effondrait quand vous dit l'immobilier
est à -5% vous dites très bien mais je
voulais quand même pas acheter
maintenant je vais acheter quand ce sera
à -10 ça paraît toutes les transactions
et ça crée une spirale dépressive et
c'est le moment où à ce moment-là les
banques centrales apportent la liquidité
que l'économie n'apporte pas
spontanément aux banques ça rôle de
régulation qui existe depuis les temples
grecs
tomber des nues sous prétexte ça
s'appelle le Quantitative Easing
depuis les Grecs mais à l'époque des
Grecs c'était sur des actifs tangibles
oui mais enfin les économie l'économie
sous-jacente
c'est bien c'est bien tangible qu'est-ce
que ça fait les banques ça finance
massivement logement sa finance
massivement le besoin de fondrement des
entreprises ça finance les
investissements des entreprises tout ça
est bien tangible il y a en France c'est
quelle banque qui finance le logement
elles sont pas beaucoup je crois non
si vous avez pas cherché il y a six mois
un an à acquérir un appartement parce
que vous avez eu tort parce que vous
auriez emprunté je suis en train de
Crédit Agricole etc je suis en train de
bosser en ce moment sur les banques
exposées
alors que aujourd'hui vous allez la voir
malheureusement plutôt à 2,8 mais si
vous êtes chez toutes les banques
dans les agences dans les rues et pour
le logement social qui est un modèle
économique différent ou vous ne prêtez
pas
à vous et moi vous prêtez à des
collectivités territoriales ou à des
offices qui sont dédiés à des
investissements de logements social vous
avez un réseau de banque publique
rassemblés autour de la Caisse des
dépôts et consignations et où beaucoup
est apporté par la
Poste La Banque Postale beaucoup est
apportée par les caisses d’épargne par
tous les livrets
réglementés livret A les livrets de
développement durable etc et qui est
vraiment spécialisé dans le logement
social qui qui n'est pas la même chose
que votre logement que vous allez
chercher vous allez chercher votre
financement dans une banque commerciale
donc vous avez un système qui fonctionne
qui est beaucoup plus robuste que le
système américain il y a pas de
subprimes
ce qu'on faisait dans le système
américain qui était une bulle
spéculative
c'était dans des thés des gens
non pas sur leur revenu mais sur la
valeur de leur bien en pensant s'il leur
arrive de ne pas être capable de payer
c'est pas grave le prix des maisons aux
États-Unis augmente régulièrement on
revendra leur maison et on se
remboursera enfin on le fait pas ça on
ne vous prête pas avec l'idée que votre
logement va coûter de plus en plus cher
donc c'est pas grave on vous en privera
en vous on arrive le saisira pour
rembourser on le fait sur la base de
votre capacité de remboursement en
revenus c'est un système qui dominant en
Europe continentale et qui fait que nous
n'avons pas de subprimes n'avons pas des
gens non solvables à qui on prête quand
même de l'argent c'est 10 ans ça va
monter toujours parce qu'évidemment dès
que le marché du mobilier baisse en prix
le système s'effondre puisque les gens
n'ont pas les revenus pour rembourser et
les maisons que l'on va saisir vaudront
moins que leur prix d'achat et donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé en 2008
quand on a une grosse récession que les
gens perdent leur travail et ne peuvent
plus rembourser
non mais
deux choses vous êtes dans des pays
comme grosso modo la France l'Allemagne
les pays scandinaves dans lesquels vous
avez une indemnisation du chômage
convenable les gens ne sont pas prévus
les gens ne sont pas privés de leur
revenu
totalement et complètement vous avez
également des pays à peu près les mêmes
qui ont un modèle social dans lequel on
peut négocier si on est surendetté
d'ailleurs un sujet dont s'occupe
directement la Banque de France fait
partie de ces missions à la banque
centrale donc si vous voulez vous n'êtes
pas comme dans une situation dans un
autre modèle social qui est le modèle
américain jusqu'à un certain point le
modèle britannique
en situation de perdre votre de votre
logement et quand vous perdez votre
emploi aux États-Unis
vous perdez également votre retraite
très très souvent puisque votre retraite
elle est gérée par des fonds et c'est la
retraite d'entreprise c'est pas une
retraite collective et vous perdez très
souvent vos droits à la santé
parce qu'il dépendent du fait que soit
vous avez une protection grâce à
l'entreprise soit vous êtes capable de
payer une assurance privée pour votre
santé mais c'est pas du tout le modèle
européen quand vous perdez votre travail
vous ne perdez pas
votre revenu votre droit à la santé et
votre droit à retraite de la même façon
donc évidemment que c'est une crise
majeure qu'on cherche à éviter par tous
les moyens d'entrer en récession mais ça
n'a pas les mêmes effets ça a des effets
beaucoup plus brutaux là où le modèle
social n'est pas le modèle social
européen
le glastiegel actes vous voyez ce que
c'est est-ce que vous pouvez nous
l'expliquer est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire les intérêts pas les intérêts
d'avoir un GLAST Eagle Act c'est quoi le
glastiegel actes
de la prière
c'est que aux États-Unis c'est plus
c'est plus fragile d'avoir un système
bancaire vous avez sous le même toit une
fonction de banque qui fait du crédit
commercial et une des banques qui font
de l'investissement et qui sont des
banques d'affaires
oui qui parce que elle travaille
beaucoup sur les marchés
sont
affectés par la volatilité des marchés
parce que quand vous êtes une banque qui
ouvre des comptes qui collecte donc de
l'épargne qui ensuite vous fait du
crédit au logement à la consommation etc
vous n'avez pas une très grande
volatilité évidemment en période de fort
chômage forte de fortes récession vous
avez des crédits douteux parce que les
entreprises vont beaucoup moins bien ce
genre de choses mais au total c'est
quand même relativement stable les
banques d'affaires autorisaient à faire
des opérations de marché
vous avez vu des corrections
des des valeurs de marché des indices de
marché aujourd'hui le
prenait le marché français le CAC 40 est
autour de 6700 points mais
quand il y a des corrections il peut il
peut descendre à la moitié à 3000 à 3500
vous pouvez vous retrouver tout à fait
avec plusieurs expériences dans les 20
dernières années avec la valeur divisée
par deux des titres financiers donc si
vous êtes une banque plutôt orientée
vers les opérations de marché de
capitaux
vous êtes avec un degré de dangerosité
plus élevé vous devez avoir donc des
sécurités vous devez avoir plus de
capital pour absorber plus de choc et
vous pouvez faire aussi beaucoup plus de
profils donc accumuler du capital qui
vous permettra d'être plus résilient
parce que parce que parce que les
marchés peuvent également monter un bal
de balle 3
ça consiste à demander aux banques de
prendre de plus en plus de couverture de
fonds propres pour cent par rapport à
leur exposition
capitale de premier rang le plus dur le
plus
protecteur ça ne peut pas être inférieur
à 10% et et vaut beaucoup mieux que ce
soit très supérieur à 10% et donc les
traités les traités les instructions de
la banque dérèglement internationaux qui
siège à base et qui est une banque des
c'est
de renforcer par des décisions qui
s'imposent à tous le niveau de
protection c'est à dire simplement le
coussin d'épargne en fait
sur
l'auto assurance des banques bon et
c'est parce qu'on a beaucoup augmenté
avec sur l'appel balle de balle 3 que en
covid avec une récession mondiale très
importante bien plus importante qu'en
2008-2009 n'a pas eu de pays de
banquière significative mais pour
revenir à votre question
glace sigle acte
pour éviter une nouvelle crise de 29 les
États-Unis ont décidé que les banques de
marché banque d'affaires ne serait pas
solidaire donc serait forcément des
entreprises indépendantes les unes des
autres
on est petit à petit un peu revenu de
cela parce que en réalité de nos jours
c'est moins c'est appliqué d'une façon
moins rigoureusement enfin il reste
quand même que
il y a plus de danger les mêmes et
berstone qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
c'était de ces banques d'affaires et de
marcher et qui ont été très affectés par
le fait que les marchés se sont très
rapidement dégradés au point d'être
insolvable de ne pas pouvoir
financer leurs clients et rembourser
leur dette au reste du système bancaire
donc grosso modo on reste encore
aujourd'hui donc quelque chose d'assez
dominant de séparation des banques les
plus vulnérables
avec les ventes les plus robustes
le rebord le rebord le Libor le
petit affaire c'était des petits copains
sur les salles de marché qui
s'entendaient c'était quoi
non mais
il n'y a pas que il n'y a pas que des
gens intègrent et ça dans tous les
métiers et donc il se trouve que quand
il est pas intègre c'est pas bien grave
mon pilote d'avion s'il est pas intègre
s'y prendre la drogue si l'alcoolique
c'est plus problématique oui
oui
vaut mieux que les gens soient intègre
et et qu'ils aient des comportements
normés
toute une série de de spéculation et
toute une série de fraude bon et donc il
y a eu des calculs d'intérêt sur la base
sur une base on prend une base commune
toutes les banques pour appliquer un
taux d'intérêt à client à une entreprise
client et puis on dit qu'on discute
de la marge au dessus
de cette base commune acceptée et il se
trouve que le Liber que vous dites c'est
la base
de taux d'intérêt du marché de Londres
qui est le plus important de de la de
l'Europe et à des plus importants du
monde rebor c'est pour l'Europe
continentale et puis vous êtes un client
beaucoup plus solvable que moi donc
beaucoup plus respectable et vous allez
donc avoir une marge à payer à votre
banque mais plus faible que la mienne
parce que moi je
comporte un risque plus important
maintenant si vous trichez dans vos
contrats sur le niveau du Liban
en jouant de l'ignorance de vos clients
en fait vous faites des marges
supplémentaires de façon frauduleuse et
quand le régulateur les contrôleurs
passent et découvrent ça
ils incriminent et mettant en prison un
certain nombre de gens qui ont fait
gagner à leur établissement ou à
eux-mêmes et parce qu'ils ont souvent
des bonus de trader
c'est à dire de ces gens qui font ce
genre de transaction
très élevé
et au fond la justice passe et ça fait
un scandale
en parlant de justice mais les scandales
rapportaient
mondiale les scandales sont très petits
qu'on découvre ou que le régulateur
découvre non
ça occupe une grande partie des gens
dans le métier financier que de de faire
des fraudes qui vont donner des
scandales c'est totalement marginal
merci de le préciser c'est totalement
non mais je veux dire il y a de la
délinquance financière ça va de soi ça
va de soi comme il y a des vacances dans
tous les dans tous les domaines mais
vous ne pouvez pas vous ne pouvez pas
dire que le système financier est
principalement
journée à la recherche
de fraude vous avez remarqué j'ai jamais
dit ça
mais
vous allez quand même une petite
tonalité
je vous donnerai à penser je vous donne
l'opportunité proportions mafieuse dans
le système judiciaire
de défendre votre métier et d'expliquer
aux gens pourquoi c'est nécessaire
d'avoir des banques qui irriguent le
tissu industriel et social et si vous
voulez je vous donne
franchement je me suis jamais assis
auprès de quelqu'un lui disant bon je
vais te prendre une marge à cause de ton
risque etc et donc évidemment je sais de
quoi il s'agit revenons la justice en
2008 mise à part en Islande quelles sont
les banquiers qui ont été en tôle
il y a eu des il y a eu des sujets
de délinquance donc bérings par exemple
qui était une banque très honorée
des traders qui ont fait perdre des
milliards à la banque qui est d'ailleurs
fait faillite vous avez comme ça des
sujets de ce type maintenant si vous
voulez me faire dire que la crise
financière
était le fait des patrons de banque et
qu'ils auraient été bien en prison par
exemple je sais pas le patron de Lehman
si vous voulez après tout c'est une
crise qui survient parce que Lehman a
créé un choc systémique tout à l'heure
pourquoi n'est-il pas en prison parce
qu'il a créé parce qu'il n'a pas commis
de délits il a commis des fautes de
gestion et ces défauts de gestion où
elles ont un caractère délictueux pénal
ou pas donc il y a eu des enquêtes il y
a des enquêtes sont assez sévères aux
États-Unis faites par le majorité des
marchés la SEC et donc on peut faire
confiance à la franchement aux autorités
judiciaires procureur
général de New York etc et donc vous
avez eu tous ceux qui ont fait des
comités
patron d'une banque qui par exemple est
démi par son conseil d'administration
parce qu'elle fait des pertes avec un
criminel monsieur Madoff
lui a monté un système totalement
du système de Ponzi mais totalement
frauduleux bon donc monsieur madame a
été connaît à 120 ans de prison bon mais
ce n'est pas parce que vous faites des
pertes
dans un contexte de récession que vous
avez commis des délits ou des crimes par
conséquent
si vous aviez voulu que tous les patrons
de banque qui ont fait des pertes en
en prison
il y en a eu beaucoup parce qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de pertes
et vous les auriez extrait de prison
quand en 2010 ils avaient tous retrouvé
leur niveau de de profil antérieur
il se trouve que le fait de faire des
pertes
[Musique]
vous voyez le système financier comment
avec la guerre avec la Russie et
l'Ukraine avec les tensions entre les
États-Unis et la Chine le système
financier mondial vous le percevez
comment on s'approche vers un autre
carton on s'approche vers une situation
qui serait correctement gérée par les
banques centrales
comment vous percevez la chose
c'est une situation qui est
très très inconfortable pour beaucoup
d'acteurs la situation actuelle
maintenant c'est assez logique parce que
on est en situation de guerre ouverte
en Europe ce qui phénomène complètement
nouveau de conflictualité accrue ou de
risque de conflit
exacerbé beaucoup de régions évidemment
à Taïwan
évidemment à l'est du Congo
évidemment avec le risque nucléaire
de l'Iran
peut être tout moment exacerber des
conflits qui sont bien réels
est un lieu de guerre entre l'Arabie
Saoudite et l'Iran
et bien des égards la Syrie est encore
bon donc dans une situation qui est
extrêmement
tout de même dangereuse
ajoutez à ça que vous sortez d'une
pandémie qui est un choc très fort et la
plus forte récession connue de
l'histoire c'est plus fort que la crise
de 29 ça a donc des séquelles
et même dans les aspects positifs c'est
déstabilisant c'est à dire en 2021 on
rattrape
mais on crée partout des pénuries
et on installe l'inflation c'est comme
vous avez des pénuries
mécaniquement vous avez des hausses de
prix très importantes pour ce qui est en
pénurie il y a dessus des lois
économiques très précises
c'est pas simplement un phénomène de
spéculation quand il y a des pénurie il
y a une inflation très forte
or on s'est beaucoup pendetté pendant le
vide
c'était beaucoup endetté également pour
purger la crise 2002-2009 donc on a des
hausses de taux d'intérêt lié à
l'inflation et donc on a une session
très inconfortable pour beaucoup
d'acteurs
ajoutons quelque chose que par exemple
nous en Afrique on ressemble beaucoup
c'est que le dollar c'est
imposer
par rapport à toutes les autres monnaies
parce que très vite la banque centrale
américaine la Fédérale réserve pour
enrayer l'inflation américaine qui était
plus forte qu'ailleurs a fait monter les
taux et donc il est plus rémunérateur
d'acheter des dollars que d'acheter des
titres en euros en yen en livre sterling
quel que soit la nature des autres
devises
et donc vous avez eu dans le système
financier en plus cette appréciation du
dollar donc le dollar c'est plus un 15
contre euros c'est l'euro à 0,98 ou à
parité avec le dollar il n'y a pas que
l'euro qui baissait la livre sterling a
beaucoup plus baissé il faut soutenir le
yen japonais le yuan chinois
je ne parle pas du rang de sud-africain
du Schilling kenyan vous avez un choc de
la ça fait quand même beaucoup vous avez
de l'inflation vous avez de la hausse
des taux vous avez la monnaie mondiale
la monnaie qui sert à étalonner toutes
les transactions importantes la monnaie
de cotation tous les grands marchés
autour de cette monnaie déjà autour de
du dollar c'est quoi le proverbe
je vois pas notre monnaie vos problèmes
c'est une facétie des gens qui détestent
les États-Unis
non je pensais que vous alliez me
trouver quelque chose dans la sagesse
soviétique ou dans une fable de La
Fontaine non ça c'est juste de
l'anti-américanisme si vous voulez c'est
bon mais non
sur les proverbes je suis pas très bon
surtout surtout quand c'est pas des
problèmes enfin bon donc si vous voulez
on a quand même tous ces facteurs
additionnels comme ça de déstabilisation
du système financier cela étant on n'a
pas
de choc du côté des banques
franchement on aurait été en 2007 et on
suivrait la même chose
il y aurait pas eu tous les progrès
un peu de résilience des banques à cause
de la crise de 2008-2009 je pense que là
on aurait on aurait vraiment déjà vécu
des faillites systémiques du système
bancaire donc au moins ça ça tient ça
tient debout mais en revanche les
entreprises en souffrent beaucoup
leur coûts augmente et leur coût
financier en plus et donc oui il y a
aujourd'hui un système financier qui
n'épargne pas les ménages
et qui n'épargne pas les entreprises
et dans les pays les plus vulnérables
qui ont des monnaies moins robustes je
vous dis quand déjà la livre sterling le
yen japonais et l'euro baisse
significativement il y a évidemment des
monnaies beaucoup plus fragiles et c'est
le cas dans les pays émergents la Livre
Turque etc et dans les pays en
développement comme chez nous en Afrique
et donc vous importez une inflation
extraordinaire parce que non seulement
le gaz a augmenté non seulement le blé a
augmenté mais comme il est facturé en
dollars qui lui-même a augmenté donc le
prix de la marchandise
en dollars et plus élevé mais le dollar
vaut plus par rapport et donc vous avez
une dissémination mondiale
de la crise liée à la surchauffe de 2021
et à la guerre en Ukraine et
objectivement c'est beaucoup de
souffrance le système financier tient
donc ce que vous vous interrogez sur le
système financier je vous réponds les
banques tiennent les banques centrales
pilotent la chose
elles font monter les taux d'intérêt
pour décourager l'inflation dès qu'il y
aura des signes que l'inflation baisse
est taux d'intéresse poseront ça sera
une période un tout petit peu plus
stable on est probablement à deux trois
mois de cela
peut-être les marchés financiers vont
réussir à ne pas craquer mais en
revanche l'économie réelle
sous-jacente surtout des pays émergents
et des pays en développement souffrent
beaucoup et donc il y a beaucoup de
souffrance dans certains pays ça prend
des formes graves de famille parce que
vous pouvez plus importer la nourriture
que vous ne produisez pas vous-même
dans d'autres pays ça paralyse la
production industrielle parce que vous
gaz pétrole sont devenus très chers
surtout le gaz alors c'était surtout
terrible pendant jusqu'à il y a trois
mois
là vous observez que le gaz a quand même
baissé en prix significativement si vous
voulez
l'indicateur de longue période du gaz de
l'unité
qu'on traite sur les marchés était
plutôt à 40 en longue période et monter
jusqu'à 400
au premier semestre
et les retombées à 80 à cause des
capacités de stockage plein pot oui
parce qu'en fait il y avait pas une
pénurie si grande que celle qui était
imaginée et le retrait russe n'était pas
n'avait pas un impact si fort et
aujourd'hui vous avez des réserves
dans les pays qui dépendent du gaz qui
paraissent à peu près suffisantes donc
c'est deux fois le prix de long période
mais ça n'est pas les 400 les 10 fois
qui ont créé une panique mais en
attendant pour beaucoup d'entreprises
beaucoup de ménages sur le chauffage sur
tout processus industriel
un certain nombre d'entreprises à
s'arrêter les verriers
s'arrêtent va prendre 15 millions auprès
de l'État donc ça va aller leur
permettre de un petit un petit peu la
République française
c'est pas forcément il y a des états qui
sont capables de soutenir dans une
entreprise il y en a qui ne le sont pas
donc c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
souffrance et c'est très inégalitaire
donc moi je me fais pas énormément de
soucis pour le système financier qui
tient
je me fais du souci pour l'économie
réelle et franchement dans les pays les
plus vulnérables la situation est
vraiment critique
notre ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le
Maire nous annonce qu'on est sur un
plateau d'inflation que l'inflation va
baisser on croise tous les doigts pour
que monsieur le ministre a raison
mais je vais je vais être un petit peu
faire l'avocat du diable si l'inflation
baisse est-ce que c'est parce que il y a
une énorme récession qui arrive
moi je pense que l'inflation va baisser
vite
je pense que
il y a la crainte d'une récession
et il y a la hausse des taux d'intérêt
qui fait craindre une récession la
hausse est un quelque chose d'intérêt
c'est pour que les entreprises sont
d'être le moins possible investissement
possible
et ça c'est un facteur de récession
important
que les ménages sont d'être le moins
possible
et donc ça va contracter contracter en
effet
l'activité donc
pourquoi je pense que c'est c'est une
inflation qui va être modérée parce que
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'indexation
systématique et la spirale qui fait que
l'inflation dure très longtemps
si on se met à tous les revenus
sur les prix
ça augmente les coûts les prix
augmentent encore plus et on a comme ça
une échelle dans laquelle on entretient
l'inflation pendant des années dans la
plupart des pays on répond par des
mesures de soutien de prime ou de
subventions temporaire qui sont pas une
indexation automatique
tu me dis que j'ai 10% d'inflation je
fais 10% d'augmentation des salaires
ça va durer 10 ans si vous dites il y a
10% d'inflation ça vous coûte à vous tel
ménage
si vous vouliez maintenir votre pouvoir
d'achat 700 euros 800 euros
vous allez les recevoir comme une aide
de l'État par exemple on va vous
abaissez le prix du du
de l'essence de carburant où on va
bloquer le prix du fioul domestique pour
le chauffage
où on fait une on demande à vos
employeurs et l'État premier employeur
vous donne des primes
vous avez une chance que lorsque
l'inflation baisse on est on n'est pas
perpétué par l'indexation le phénomène
d'inflation regardez le pétrole le
pétrole il a atteint des niveaux de
l'ordre de 120 dollars le baril mais il
est retombé à 80 et pour qu'il reste
entre 80 et 90 les pays pétroliers ont
dû enlever des quantités de pétrole par
rapport à ce qu'ils produisent tous les
jours les États-Unis tu es pas content
il se trouve que c'est une décision des
pays producteurs de pétrole le PEP et le
paie plus c'est à dire la Russie en plus
et qui n'en sont pas membres donc et qui
d'ailleurs qui elle s'est construite
cette organisation du pays contre les
États-Unis et contre l'Europe de l'Ouest
donc eux ils protègent leurs intérêts
leurs intérêts c'est que le pétrole
reste entre 80 et 90 90 et 100
idéalement parce qu'ils ont pour les
pays en développement producteur de
pétrole ils ont des besoins de
rattrapage parce qu'il y a eu un prix
très bas du pétrole pendant 5 ou 6 ans
et donc ça
retardé énormément le développement et
pour les pays riches et développés
producteurs de pétrole ils sont partis
dans des dans des investissements
considérables comme l'Arabie Saoudite
les Émirats cathares etc notamment pour
préparer la prépétrole donc ils ont
absolument besoin mais ça veut dire que
le ils ont besoin d'un pétrole assez
cher pas trop cher mais assez cher et du
coup
ils enlèvent des quantités pour être sûr
qu'il reste à faire donc aujourd'hui
vous voyez que quelque chose qui
pourrait faire baisser la flexion plus
vite c'est la baisse du prix du pétrole
et piloter pour que ça n'aille pas trop
vite à la baisse mais c'est ça la
tendance le gaz a beaucoup baissé le
pétrole a une tendance baissière et
petit à petit parce que les céréales
sont quand même sorties de Russie en
partie du kraine le même pour les huiles
alimentaires de même parce que la montée
en puissance des composants
électroniques qui étaient en pleine
pénurie parce que les volumes de
logistique les containers sont redevenus
à un prix normal etc donc en réalité
c'est beaucoup lié à des pénuries qui
sont liées à des événements c'est pas
une inflation
naturel lié à un excès de demande c'est
des paralysies de l'offre et donc
priori c'est une inflation qui devrait
se résorber assez vite à condition qu'on
ne perpétue pas le conflit ukrainien
à condition qu'on n'est pas tout d'un
coup
une crise à Taïwan
une crise de Taïwan poserait problème
gravissime avec la Chine et déjà la
Chine fort ralentissement économique
ce sont des facteurs
de stagnation comme on dit on pourrait
rester en inflation tout en étant en pas
loin de la récession enfin à croissance
zéro et là on serait mal pour longtemps
la stagnation avec des mots plus simples
c'est le prix de l'immobilier qui qui
tombe et le prix de l'alimentaire qui
augmente c'est ça
c'est d'abord de la stagnation et c'est
ça que des sciences ça veut dire vous
êtes la croissance zéro bon de toute
façon 0 créez pas d'emploi le chômage
monte etc donc premier dégât et en plus
vous avez de l'inflation donc ça veut
dire que
alors que vous avez moins de revenus
distribués les prix continuent à être
élevés donc l'alimentation le chauffage
etc
le carburant pour aller au travail tout
ça continue d'être cher alors que les
revenus diminuent c'est une situation
extrêmement désagréable et qui peut
durer longtemps alors il y a quelques
actifs donc par exemple l'immobilier qui
à ce moment-là se met à baisser parce
que les gens au fond ne peuvent plus
accéder à certains actifs donc ils
achètent moins d'immobilier ils achètent
moins d'actions sur les marchés donc
marché baisse et donc vous êtes dans une
situation
qui peut-être la pire
vous avez de vrais comporter au pouvoir
d'achat vous avez des inégalités
considérables dans une situation sociale
très très très difficile donc tout le
sujet et d'un pêcher cette impression de
durer
qu'est-ce que c'est un choc volcœur
c'est c'est amusant mais puisque vous
buvez dans l'histoire monétaire c'est
impressionné
sous folker patron de la Fédérale
réserve ironique non mais ça même ça
m'impressionne votre goût pour
l'histoire monétaire je suis ravi c'est
quoi le proverbe c'est cogner ton passé
si tu veux connaître l'avenir non
respecte beaucoup les proverbes mais
souvent ils sont poétiques vous avez des
drôles de proverbes qui ne sont pas des
premières du tout d'ailleurs voilà je
crois c'est mon impression
je suis pas poils
des États-Unis
à conduit les taux d'intérêt
à deux chiffres
pas très loin de 20% pour éradiquer
une inflation non maîtrisable après les
chocs pétroliers
et donc il y a des gens pour craindre
alors qu'on pouvait s'endetter à 1%
même des PME
des ménages
pas très très fortunés
il y a une crainte chez certains qu'on a
jusqu'à donner un choc terrible à
l'économie
en dépassant à des taux supérieurs à 10%
ce qui ferait en un an un an et demi à
choc absolument considérable et des gens
qui s'entendettés à taux variable
bon évidemment des surprises terribles
parce que ils ont fait leur calcul
d'entreprise ou de particulier à la et
demi et puis et puis il passe à 10 ou 15
mais on était dans une autre situation
rappelez-vous que quand François
Mitterrand arrive en 1981 aux affaires
l'inflation en France et le 14%
et depuis les chocs pétroliers depuis 77
donc c'est s'installe on est à 14% de
réflexion et tout le travail qui est
terminé avec certains succès par Pierre
Bérégovoy c'est de ramener en dessous de
5%
l'inflation Jacques Delore Pierre Perret
gaubois et on y arrive en fait mais ça
aurait été dix ans d'une inflation forte
et aux États-Unis ça a été éradiqué par
une hausse des taux absolument
considérable qui arrête l'activité donc
la demande s'effondre quand la demande
s'effondre les prix finissent par
s'effondrer aussi donc
la crainte d'un choc de ce type a existé
maintenant personne n'y croit le taux de
chômage avec un choc Walker on laisse
filer donc non mais chômage aux
Etats-Unis est très différent du chômage
en Europe
parce que les États-Unis sont très
volatiles en ce moment ils sont en super
plein emploi
en tension extraordinaire sur le sur le
marché du travail c'est à dire que
il n'y a pas de chômage aux Etats-Unis
le taux de 3% de chômage aux États-Unis
c'est juste la mesure de ce qu'on
appelle l'emploi frictionnaire chômage
frictionnel des gens qui sont entre deux
emplois et qui sont inscrits au chômage
pour des indemnités de brève période et
en revanche il y a des pénuries partout
en France aussi mais en France les
niveaux de pleine emploi sont différents
parce que l'indemnisation du chômage en
France
et comme dans les grands pays où il y a
un État providence et un modèle social
européen et social-démocrate disons-le
il y a
des gens qui ne sortent pas du chômage
parce que l'indemnisation du chômage
leur permet une vie décente
ce qui est pas du tout le cas aux
États-Unis et pas du tout le cas en
Grande-Bretagne et d'ailleurs le pays
probablement qui va être le plus
éprouvé en Europe dans les mois qui
viennent ça risque d'être la
Grande-Bretagne et la Grande-Bretagne
n'a pas des filets la Grande-Bretagne
n'a pas d'état Providence au même niveau
que les pays d'Europe continentale et
donc
le choc social en Grande-Bretagne risque
d'être très fort aux États-Unis si vous
avez un effet de chômage qui arrêtera en
effet la politique de restriction
monétaire
vous aurez probablement assez vite
derrière un réemploi des salariés c'est
des mouvements beaucoup beaucoup plus
rapide
pourquoi le FMI tape sur les doigts de
la France sur sa politique de quoi qu'il
en coûte pourquoi le FMI râle
le FMI est dans un rôle de police de
vous rappeler les règles des règles du
permis de conduire donc le permis de
conduire si vous voulez c'est
faites pas difficile budgétaire
enfin faites-en au moins le moins
possible
respecter les 3% idéal qui sont l'idéal
du déficit budgétaire or la France et
l'Europe en général vous savez la
formule du quoiqu'il en coûte elle n'a
pas été inventée par Emmanuel Macron
était évoqué d'abord été défini en
anglais whatever takes par Mario Draghi
président de la Banque centrale
européenne
italien et ça a été la politique de la
Banque centrale européenne on empêchera
la récession whatever it takes quoi
qu'il en coûte et s'agissant du covid
la réponse française mais de fait la
réponse de la plupart du pays Européens
on fera le soutien aux entreprises et le
soutien aux ménage qu'il faut donc on
paiera automatiquement du chômage ce que
les Allemands appellent le cours de
sarbyte
et
on sera automatique et très rapide et
les entreprises recevront ce qu'il faut
de pré garantir de moratoire de façon à
ce qu'elle reste debout pourquoi parce
que l'Allemagne a fait ça en 2009
et l'Allemagne qui avait un taux de
chômage
un peu plus élevé que la France en 2007
est passé de 2009 à 2019
en façon linéaire à une baisse régulière
du chômage jusqu'à être en 2019 à 3 %
qu'on considère comme le plein emploi en
Allemagne 3% de chômeurs pourquoi parce
qu'en 2008-2009 c'est le seul pays qui
avait massivement
soutenu les entreprises pour qu'elles ne
fasse pas faillite pour qu'elle puisse
redémarrer très très vite et massivement
les ménages payants du Corsa bike du
chômage
partiel très bien indemnisé pour ne pas
perdre les compétences et redémarrer
très vite et c'est le pays qui a le
mieux redémarré et qui a effectivement
fait des progrès considérables entre
2009-2019 c'est cela qu'on m'a dit comme
généralisé et regardez là dans la lutte
contre l'inflation de l'énergie des prix
de l'énergie l'Allemagne vient de
débloquer 200 milliards d'euros qui est
le programme le plus important de le
pays de l'Union européenne de même
qu'elle a accepté que l'Union européenne
est un green compact
d'accélération de la transition
énergétique avec des dettes assumées et
donc remboursé en commun
750 milliards d'euros on n'avait jamais
accepté en Allemagne d'être solidaire
avec les autres pays européens dans des
dettes de l'Union européenne et non pas
de tel ou tel pays de la Grèce de
l'Italie etc bon ça c'est des signes que
le whatever it takes Mario Draghi ou le
quoiqu'il en coûte de Emmanuel Macron
reste la politique des États européens
conformes à leur modèle social ça a
plutôt bien réussi en termes de capacité
de reprise en 2021 et le Fond monétaire
est
pédagogue du conservatisme et explique
ce serait mieux maintenant vous êtes en
train de vous surendetter de vous calmer
et de faire des économies maintenant le
le
déficit de la France est beaucoup moins
important que ce que les gens
annonçaient et en fait on est plutôt à
six et demi
pour cent du pub alors qu'on nous
prévoyait un déficit budgétaire à neuf
6,6 c'est pas quelque chose de de
scandaleux et pourquoi parce que les
recettes
public
sont en progression significative pour
des raisons simples les entreprises ont
fait des bons résultats en 2021 qui
donnent lieu à des recettes fiscales de
ce que les revenus des ménages en France
n'ont pas souffert pendant le covid
pour cent de croissance pour combien de
milliards injectés
les soutiens les soutiens à l'économie
ont dû représenter du fait de l'État
quelque chose comme 5% du PIB donc le
PIB français
vous avez en tête que c'est un peu au
nord de 2500 milliards d'euros donc vous
êtes devant
quelque chose autour de 125 milliards
injectés dans l'économie pour la
soutenir et ça ça vous fait passer un
déficit budgétaire ça se passe par le
budget de quelque chose comme 4-5% qui
est au-dessus de ce qu'on considère
comme le plus saint
et ça fait passer à 9 ou 10 et puis
ensuite la reprise vient les recettes
fiscales sont plus élevées que ce qu'on
pensait vous savez
je suis au conseil et d'ailleurs je le
préside d'un signe tank qui s'appelle
Terra Nova on a publié une note
en avril 2020 en plein Lockdown plein
confinement
parce que la spéculation des gens
c'était
l'économie centrale s'effondrer
tous les secteurs s'arrêtent dans le
monde entier donc on va vers une crise
abyssale et on a effectivement une
récession en Europe de 8% et on mettra
des années à s'en sortir
et donc il y a des gens qui vous
dessinez des cours en disant s'effondre
puis après on va avoir des hoquets comme
ça ce sera une courbe en W les plus
pessimistes qui ont toujours un succès
énorme dans les crises
je trouve toujours mais ça a toujours le
même succès vous êtes en sera une courbe
en elle c'est à dire d'abord ça s'effond
et ensuite ça reste au plus bas et on
sortira on reviendra à 2019 peut-être en
2025 26 nous on a sorti une note pour
dire à partir de l'ensemble des
informations et de l'historique ce qu'on
a en main c'est très simple à la sortie
en mai-juin du locqda européen au
troisième trimestre on aura déjà une
reprise en V absolument incroyable
c'est tout à fait ce qui s'est passé
quand vous arrêtez une économie
brutalement
mais mais d'ordre public
vous êtes à la même situation on avait
été en 1968 en France simplement il y a
pas 10 millions de gens confinés il y
avait 10 millions de grévis vous avez
perdu 8 semaines de production
dans le trimestre qui a suivi le
rattrapage
de cette interruption qui n'est pas
économique qui est sociale dans le cas
de 2020 c'est pas économique c'est
sanitaire on est obligé de s'arrêter
très bien dès qu'on reprend vous aviez
eu une croissance de la richesse créée
du PIB français de 37% au troisième
trimestre 2008 de 1968 vous avez
exactement la même chose
au troisième trimestre de 2020 donc
faire un tout petit peu attention sur
les prévisions du style la crise va
durer toujours l'inflation va durer
toujours
pas du tout on a des capacités de
rattrapage très forte et donc en 2021
2022 par rapport à toutes les prévisions
pessimistes le déficit le quoiqu'il en
couple français était évidemment bien
moins dans ses effets que ce que nous
ont raconté tous les gens qui nous
expliquent qu'on va crouler sous leur
sous la dette et que nos enfants seront
ensevelis sous la dette à la sortie de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale la France
était endettée à 200% du PIB au début de
la 5ème République en 1958 elle était
endettée à 25% ce qui paye les dettes
c'est la croissance on a une croissance
exceptionnelle en 21 et forte 22 et donc
c'est ça qui fait que nous sommes pas
dans un déficit qui pose problème donc
le quoi qu'il en coûte était raisonnable
la croissance c'est un peu basé sur
l'énergie non
la consommation énergétique absolument
va faire pour l'instant
la pénurie elle n'est pas sur le pétrole
elle est sur le gaz mais dans les
proportions qu'on a décrite c'est elle
que oui vous êtes au double du prix de
longue période mais on sortait d'une
longue période de prix bas du gaz
mais elle est pas 10 fois le prix qu'on
a vu au moment de la panique Gasprom va
tout fermer et le monde va
arrêter ces industries les gens vous
décrivez une Allemagne toutes les
entreprises allaient industrielle elle
allait s'arrêter ça ce sont des des
paniques mais qui ont un effet
spéculatif sur les prix considérables et
qui finissent par avoir des effets de
déstabilisation sociale considérable
vous avez vu le passage dans la de
Christine Lagarde c'était sur une chaîne
néerlandaise non
le
présentateur lui pose la question mais
alors toutes ces nets toutes ces lettres
quand est-ce qu'on est en bourse
elle répond indu ou course
le temps venu
si vous voulez
c'est un grand classique
de faire du pathos de la dette
alors nous comme africain
on nous fait sans arrêt ce genre de
procès absurde vous êtes surendetté en
Afrique c'est insupportable alors là
pour l'instant on est en train de faire
ça aux Européens de pro c'est un peu
nouveau vous êtes en train de sortir
sont des baliverts si vous regardez
l'histoire économique bon moi je voulais
je suis pas un très bon économiste sauf
que j'enseignais de l'histoire
économique
vous ne trouverez aucun exemple sauf des
exemples avec des canonnières et des
pressions militaires ou des pays
croulent sous les dettes que Haïti a été
mis à genoux dans toute son histoire par
l'indemnité quand la force
a réglé à la France
à cause de son indépendance on a voulu
faire payer
oui ça ça existe
qui a eu des folies comme par exemple le
régime de chez ocescu décidant en
Roumanie
la dette s'est épouvantable on va
rembourser toutes les dettes de la
Roumanie ce qui a appauvri la Roumanie
d'une façon inouïe qui a créé des
souffrances absolument extraordinaires
assez mal fini pour le pour le régime
donc ce genre de situation
extraordinaire quelqu'un de fou qui dit
l'État ne peut pas vivre avec des dettes
je vais tout rembourser
j'arrive jamais dans l'histoire mais bon
on assure le service de la dette on se
réendette pour rembourser les dettes
précédentes donc ça c'est vous avez chez
secoue vous avez Haïti pour le reste il
faut arrêter avec le pathos de la dette
lorsque l'économie sera en expansion et
quand elle l'a été en 2021 et au premier
semestre 2022 on a déjà remboursé
beaucoup de dettes
deuxièmement l'inflation est une façon
de rembourser sa dette parce que
les valeurs nominales
des obligations des bancs du Trésor
n'ont pas changé simplement les prix
augmentaient de lui de 10%, les recettes
publiques les recettes du budget les
augmentent comme les prix
les autres comme les prix puisque les
gens sont taxés sur le chiffre
d'affaires taxés sur les résultats et
eux sont évoluent homothétiquement au
prix
mais elles vont plus vite que les prix
parce que vous avez pas des impôts dans
un monde moderne qui sont des impôts
proportionnels je vous taxe à 10%, vous
avez des épaules progressifs plus vous
gagnez plus je vous taxe donc si vous
êtes en croissance nominale par un effet
d'inflation le taux c'est pas les 10%
c'est 11 12 jusqu'à 40
pour les pour les revenus et c'est
pareil sur beaucoup d'éléments qui sont
progressifs et non pas proportionnels
donc les recettes publiques
augmentent et permettent de faire le
service de la dette
donc le pathos qui consiste à citer des
chiffres extraordinaires le coût de la
dette ça n'était c'était tombé à 30
milliards mais maintenant que les taux
d'intérêts ont augmenté et ont doublé ça
va faire 60 milliards et du coup ça va
être autant que l'éducation ça va nous
empêcher de d'augmenter les enseignants
c'est du pathos il faut regarder en
partie double
les recettes fiscales augmentent en
période d'inflation la croissance
française de 2022 en volume elle va être
de
2,5,7 c'est ça l'estimation
ce qui est beaucoup parce que en fait si
vous prenez la moyenne sur 10 ans hors
2021 c'est plutôt à 1,3 4
+ 8 % de réflexion donc en valeur vous
allez avoir une croissance
peu supérieure à 10%. mais mes recettes
publiques vont le refléter la TVA va le
refléter la CSG va le refléter l'impôt
sur les sociétés va le refléter c'est
avec ça qu'on va faire le service de la
dette tout se passe comme si on avait
des dépenses qui augmentent les recettes
qui baisent une recette augmentent
également
la dette un pathos extraordinaire encore
une fois rappelons-nous dans les
après-guerre là on est dans deux on est
dans la pré-crise du covid on n'est pas
encore dans la pré-crise de l'Ukraine on
a deux chocs incroyables les crises du
covid
on est toujours dedans mais non mais pas
du tout là
vous venez de changer de propos c'est à
dire là vous voulez qu'on parle de la
situation sanitaire vous vouliez
absolument qu'on parle des situations
financières quand vous avez fait 7 % de
croissance en volume ce que la France
n'a jamais fait c'est pas elle ne l'a
pas fait dans l'après-guerre de la
première ou de la deuxième guerre de la
jamais fait
c'est passé complètement inaperçu il
parle français pour le mot qui croit
qu'on a fait une expansion considérable
sauf que évidemment on n'a pas
d'ouvriers boulangers on n'a pas de
servir de restaurant on n'a pas de
chauffeur de on n'a pas d'informaticien
n'a pas de chauffeur on n'a pas
évidemment
on s'aperçoit quand même des effets de
la surchauffe on a fait ça plus 3%
d'inflation on a fait 10% de croissance
donc si vous voulez
d'un point de vue financier d'un point
de vue de conjoncture économique c'est
terminé la vague 1 du covid maintenant
ce que vous êtes en train de me dire
c'est oui mais enfin on en a pas
triomphé si ça se trouve ça va
recommencer bah ça sera un choc nouveau
sera une nouvelle crise d'un point de
vue économique et financier on est on
est au-dessus de 2019 on a effacé mais
c'est des chocs terribles et le choc
d'inflation est terrible donc on est
presque dans un après-guerre sauf que
c'est peut-être encore la guerre quand
on sera dans l'après-guerre
on constatera que oui ça a coûté cher et
donc on a fait de la dette c'est les
200% d'endettement de 1945 je vous dis
en 1958 13 ans après
la France est désendettée
et on sera désendetté par l'effet de la
croissance c'est la croissance et
parfois l'inflation c'est à dire que
c'est les rentiers
qui rembourse la dette c'est l'élastique
rembourse la tête parce que
leur titre de dette baisse dans leur
portefeuille donc si je vous suis bien
si je vous ai bien compris si j'ai bien
compris votre prospective c'était un bon
coup de faire des obligations d'acheter
de vendre des obligations aux banques
avec un taux variable indexé sur
l'inflation
puisque si je vous ai bien compris
l'inflation va baisser l'essentiel des
obligations les obligations des trésors
publics tato fixe
et par conséquent c'est une bonne
affaire pour l'État
si elles étaient à tout variables c'est
pas bonne affaire pour l'État si vous
savez acheter
des obligations allemandes à -05
un capteur d'intérêt négatif aux
obligations françaises à plus 0,5
si vous voulez et que l'ensemble des
prix augmentent de de 8 vous voyez bien
que petit à petit
ces obligations elles perdent 8% de leur
valeur par indécis si ça continue
les obligations
atophiques ça c'est dans l'intérêt des
rentiers des gens qui achètent des
obligations de père de famille
mais quand elles sont à taux fixe si
vous êtes en période d'inflation
voyez bien que en réalité
c'est rente perdent énormément de valeur
tous les ans vous avez confiance dans la
stabilité de l'euro
mais qu'est-ce que vous appelez la
stabilité de l'Europe là je vois que
depuis le début de l'année on perd 15%
par rapport au dollars si les sons sont
correctes est-ce que vous pensez que
l'euro va se dévaluer encore
non mais
il évalue pas se dévalorise
c'est à dire qu'il y a pas d'actes de
dévaluer sur ça c'est dans un régime de
change fixe mais il y a une
dévalorisation par terre par rapport
certaines monnaies et ne revalorisation
par rapport à d'autres monnaies
l'euro fait tout à fait son travail
c'est il y a personne qui est en train
de dire c'est terrible je veux revenir à
la peseta
même le rassemblement national n'ose
plus dire qu'il faut revenir au franc
français
même la France insoumise
n'a pas l'air d'être de mettre en cause
l'euro l'euro fait de toute façon le
travail pour assurer les paiements pour
assurer il n'y a pas de fuite devant la
monnaie si vous voulez si vous êtes au
Ghana aujourd'hui plus personne a
confiance dans la monnaie qui s'appelle
le CDI toutes l'économie est en train de
basculer en dollars vous pouvez plus
votre payer votre loyer dans la monnaie
nationale bon il y a le rôle
parfaitement stable et par ailleurs
c'est la plus grande économie du monde
si vous voulez l'Union européenne par le
ozone par conséquent elle est
parfaitement stable après vous avez un
phénomène du dollar contre toute monnaie
par contre l'euro
quand vous dites est-ce que l'euro est
dévalué mais pas du tout il est
dévalorisé contre le dollar
mais la livre sterling a baissé plus que
lui le yen à peu près comme lui
Laurent à peu près comme lui il est
stable avec l'immense majorité des
monnaies du monde il se trouve que le
dollar assez beaucoup affermi pour une
raison très simple c'est que c'est un
marché très profond très large où il y a
énormément de titres à acheter et donc
si vous êtes un épargnant et que la
République française vous propose encore
du 2%
d'acheter des bons du Trésor qui vont
porter 2% et le bon d'allemand 1%
1,5%. et qu'en ce moment le
fédéral réserve des États-Unis vous
proposent quatre et demi pourquoi
allez-vous acheter autre chose que du
dollar donc plus vous achetez des titres
en dollars plus ça fait monter la
demande de dollars donc le prix du
dollar donc c'est un phénomène du dollar
tout à fait son travail et il est si
vous devez payer en juin chinois ou en
yen japonais ou en livre sterling vous
n'avez aucune dévalorisation vous avez
une dévaluation par rapport à une
monnaie il se trouve cette monnaie très
importante parce que c'est la monnaie à
laquelle vous achetez du pétrole du blé
etc donc c'est pas anodin et après ça a
des petits
avantages et des petits dommages petit
dommage c'est que si vous êtes endetté
en dollars ça va coûter plus cher
le petit avantage c'est que vos produits
fabriqués dans des pays de l'orozone
avec des cours en euros ces produits
vont être moins chers donc vous allez
avoir plus de touristes américains parce
que l'euro est moins cher qu'avant vous
allez être plus compétitif ça c'est
l'avantage d'avoir une bonne excès
dévalorisée par rapport à la plus grande
monnaie mondiale en revanche si vous
devez des dollars à quelqu'un vous allez
devoir lui donner plus d'euros mais la
France est je vous rassure très peu
endettés en dollars ça nous pose plus
problème à nous autres pays africains
qui sommes souvent
endettés en dollars ça ça accroît le
poids de notre dette une façon gênante
pas tellement vis-à-vis du français du
dirham marocain qui sont des monnaies
assez stables enfin qui baisse un peu
comme l'euro mais c'est terrible pour
les monnaies qui sont plus fragiles et
qui elles alors par rapport au dollars
perd beaucoup plus
vous en pensez quoi
je pense que la technologie de
blockchain
présente des avantages considérables par
ce que au fond elle permet des chaînes
de contrat
entre
dans une dans une chaîne de valeur
prenez par exemple des paysans chez nous
en Afrique
leur survie en tout cas le revenu va
dépendre du fait qu'ils sont sûrs de
vendre leur récolte à un acheteur fiable
par exemple à une usine qui va leur
acheter leur noix de cajou leur maïs et
puis qui va faire de l'amidon avec ça
etc et ça ça suppose une chaîne de
contrasture et la technique de
blockchain est très intéressante pour
comment dire sécuriser du petit
agriculteur jusqu'à l'industriel et et à
partir du moment où c'est sécurisé par
un contrat
vous pouvez commencer à faire du crédit
et donner de l'assurance et chez nous ça
va être la technologie ça va être
déterminant pour le développement et
comme on a une tendance dans les pays
africains à aller très vite à adopter
les nouvelles technologies à la
différence
de l'Europe on est extrêmement rapide il
y a un président de la République
française un moment donné qui pensait
que on n'était pas rentré dans
l'histoire et qu'on était un peu
immobile sous la voûte étoilée
je connais pas les détails le cimentaire
des présidents de la République
française mais si vous voulez situer ça
dans l'histoire française c'était en
octobre 2016
vous verrez qui qui était aux affaires
mais et d'ailleurs
il en a profondément changé ensuite mais
enfin somme nous adoptons rapidement ces
choses-là donc ça c'est très très
avantageux ça ça rend les paiements
infiniment plus rapides etc en revanche
sur les crypto monnaie donc vous voyez
les grandes difficultés aujourd'hui
qui sont très spéculatives
qui utilisent la technique de blockchain
mais qu'il utilise aussi beaucoup pour
le secret des données
et qui sont donc également mais c'est
probablement marginal mais également les
les monnaies des transactions les plus
obscures qui ont besoin de rester
totalement secret
pose-moi un petit problème à cause de
cet aspect mené du crime si vous voulez
mais oublions la monnaie du crime la
violence majorité des gens participent à
ce marché ne sont pas dans dans ce
système là évidemment même si gager que
les terroristes sont d'excellents
spécialistes de la crypto monnaie
le problème c'est que vous n'avez pas de
régulation pas
le secret des données lui-même rend très
difficile la réglementation
vous n'avez donc pas de prêteur en
dernier ressort n'est pas de banque
centrale vous avez simplement des
plateformes d'échange
dans les plus importantes viennent
d'avoir des secousses très fortes et
pour l'une des plus grandes faire une
faillite parce que non réglementé
n'avait aussi une comptabilité un peu
singulière et avait fait peut-être un
peu de cavalerie et donc c'est devenu au
sens qu'on donne à cela comptabilité
c'est
manipuler des
des chiffres faux des périodes fausses
pour des fausses transactions et donc
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
d'extrêmement fragile
par ailleurs on fait rentrer sur ce
marché des gens qui n'ont pas
nécessairement des compétences
professionnelles pourront comprendre
tous les tous les tous les aspects
avec des influenceurs
un peu douteux dans l'intégrité de leurs
intentions et donc je pense globalement
que c'est un compartiment fortement en
crise de notre système financier très
spéculatif
l'Afrique du 21e siècle avec l'Europe en
crise
le prix des matières premières qui
augmentent elle va s'en sortir mieux non
ah c'est très intéressant puisque pour
le coup vous êtes un des seuls à dire ça
d'habitude on nous dit
avec les prix qui montent vous allez
surtout mourir de faim
un peu comme on nous disait en 2020
vous allez c'est vous qui allez avoir le
plus de victimes de la pandémie on a eu
beaucoup trop mais on a eu beaucoup
moins que les autres parce que l'Afrique
est un pays jeune un continent jeune
est vide
les Européens pensent que nous pullulons
en Afrique
comme on prend pas assez au sérieux dans
le secondaire la géographie donc il y a
pas assez d'Européens qui savent qu'il y
a un milieu un milliard 400 millions
d'habitants sur 30 millions de
kilomètres carrés ça fait quoi 40 km²,
c'est ça
donc on est de loin
la Sibérie si vous voulez il y a enfin
on est de loin
le continent le plus vide par ailleurs
de celui qui est le moins d'interaction
par le voyage par exemple avec les
autres pays donc il y a pas mal de
facteurs
la situation est très contrastée pour le
coup
l'Afrique est une dans beaucoup de
domaines et respire beaucoup à être une
et la plus intégrée possible mais en
fait elle est quand même différent vous
avez des producteurs de matière première
minérale l'Afrique produit les
hydrocarbures dans une quinzaine de pays
évidemment dans ces pays-là il y a
une amélioration significative des
recettes publiques des devises
des revenus mais ces quatre pays sur 54
vous avez plus intéressant les
producteurs de matières premières
minérale l'Afrique et la maîtresse et la
commence à s'en apercevoir un peu plus
les Chinois et les Américains sont
dessus depuis longtemps
et les Russes aussi
l'Afrique et la maîtresse de toutes les
rareté en matière minérale c'est-à-dire
que tout ce dont on a besoin notamment
pour la transition énergétique et terres
rares
cobaltant le nickel le lithium
c'est
en très grande abondance et d'ailleurs
probablement avec des capacités de
découverte très importante un pays comme
le mien si vous voulez on a pratiquement
aucune extraction minière
fut un temps où le BRGM qui était une
institution française qu'un bureau de
recherche géolienne
fait une cartographie du potentiel
aujourd'hui on fait des cartographies
encore beaucoup plus sophistiquées les
Russes sont très bons là-dedans français
aussi les Américains aussi
pays comme le ménage ne parle pas du
Niger ça à rien au dessus de nous
regorge des matières premières les plus
rares ce qu'on a ça va prendre quelques
années d'arriver à les exploiter avoir
les infrastructures pour les pour les
pour les sorties
minérales et ça va se tendre d'une façon
extraordinaire
prenez le bois le bois augmenté plus que
le pétrole dans la période actuelle
la forêt notamment du fleuve du bassin
du Congo est une ressource bien mieux
préservée qu'en Amazonie la deuxième
ressource au monde somme le plus grand
puis carbone du monde et de cette forêt
notamment si on y associe des
complotations agricoles sous la canopée
on peut tirer énormément de richesses
et de certificats carbone
l'Afrique a d'un point de vue
conjoncturel situation singulière où
tout ce qu'elle produit vous savez on
nous donne tout le temps des leçons mais
écoutez c'est bien simple c'est curieux
que vous ayez pas pensé vous exploitez
des matières premières brute mais
transformez-les c'est quand même pas
difficile j'adore ça quand j'étais au
gouvernement ça a été très bref je
recevais des jeunes gens
industrialisez-vous est-ce que vous
connaissez le taux d'industrie de
l'industrie dans le PIB
du Bénin ou de notre zone de l'UEMOA des
8 pays de notre zone vous le connaissez
évidemment jamais bon alors il est
supérieur auto français de contribution
de l'Afrique donc vérité tout de suite
sur le thème faites un effort
industriel et vous c'est quand même
idiot vous avez des noix de cajou vous
les envoyez en vrac
c'est pas la peine d'avoir fait un pied
pour venir me raconter ça c'est pas pour
faire de l'industrie et valoriser nos
matières premières faut du capital du
capital on en a pas du capital en
revanche votre phrase suivante
en plus de industriels ce sera ne vous
surendettez pas
oui parce que moi j'ai 47% de dettes
publiques par rapport aux PIB vous venez
d'un pays pour la France
n'est pas de la Grèce mais de la France
bon mais la France a 90% au moment se
parle maintenant c'est plus élevé mais
peut-être pas possible oui mais vous
enfin toi tu sais pas lever l'impôt
tandis que nous en France on est très
très bon pour le vélo en Allemagne aussi
etc
c'est normal que tu es deux fois moins
d'accord oui mais toi en France en
Allemagne Pays-Bas qui est un record en
Europe qui a beaucoup de crédit pour les
entreprises et pour les familles pour
les ménages
est-ce que toi c'est plutôt
moyenne européenne 150% du PIB en crédit
chaque année pour les ménages et pour
les entreprises
moi c'est 40 alors avant que tu
m'expliques que je suis sûr endetté moi
j'additionne mon 47 de dettes publiques
par rapport au PIB à mes 40 pour mes
agents économiques et 97
j'ai additionne les tiens
100% de dettes publiques actes 150% mais
ça fait 250 ok donc ces trois fois plus
que moi mais c'est quand même ça que tu
vas me dire et ça que tu veux écrire
alors de temps en temps il faut la leçon
Emmanuel Macron donc attention quoi
qu'il en coûte bon mais à moi il me la
font tous les jours en fait faut pas une
fois comme ça pose covid tous les jours
parce qu'ils connaissent rien ou quoi
non mais si vous voulez
et moralisateur donc l'Afrique est en
train de s'industrialiser parce que
c'est là que sont les emplois c'est là
que la valeur ajoutée mais pour pouvoir
se industrialiser il faut sortir les
matières premières que les extraits où
il faut sortir du sol
les matières premières agricoles ça ça
demande du capital le capital
je vous assure que c'est pas pendant la
colonisation que les indigènes l'ont
accumulé ok on était sous le régime de
l'indigena pas sous le régime de la
citoyenneté
donc ça c'est pas fait là comme ça et
donc on est dans une phase où il nous
faut accumuler du capital
et l'emprunter nous est très difficile
et très cher et en plus les gens pensent
que quand ils nous prennent de l'argent
vous remboursez pas remboursez pas et
quand on regarde les statistiques il y a
extrêmement peu de pays en défaut et
aujourd'hui il y a quatre cinq pays en
défaut en Afrique qui représentent
peut-être
5 6% du PIB de l'Afrique et 94% sont
accès d'être aussi dangereux que cela
etc et donc suivez il y a cette
situation dans le d'inégalité
d'injustice qui est extrêmement
mal vécu par nos populations et là il se
trouve que nos matières premières valent
quelque chose
et je trouve que elles vendront encore
beaucoup plus si on est capable
d'industrialiser je suis pas en train de
vous dire que pour l'Afrique qui a ses
ressources et ça c'est pas toute
l'Afrique mais c'est peut-être les deux
tiers de l'Afrique qui a ce potentiel de
terres arabes disponibles mais les seuls
et qui a c'est puis carbone naturel
c'est forêt c'est tourbières
et qui a ses capacités hydrauliques on
estime qu'on utilise 3% à nos capacités
hydrauliques pour être plus fabriquer un
barrage en Europe
là vraiment on peut faire tous les
barrages du monde
oui on se dit quand même que on va
peut-être pouvoir
de ces richesses
à condition qu'on puisse mobiliser le
capital et les compétences on va
peut-être pouvoir
accélérer notre croissance qui est déjà
vous l'avez noté dans les 10 dernières
années
à peu près trois fois celle de l'Europe
peut-être que peut-être il va se passer
quelque chose à condition qu'on
transforme ça un emploi et c'est que
notre recherche de capital et capital
humain est de connaissance c'est le
moment qu'on demande des passeport Robin
c'est ça
elle est un sport au Bénin ah oui on
pourrait faire comme les Portugais si
vous si vous investissez si vous achetez
une villa au Bénin on vous donne la on
vous donne la nationalité et il faut il
faut passer l'idée au président du Bénin
une petite question vous pensez quoi du
projet
eace
ecope de Total énergie en Ouganda leoduc
chauffer qui traversera la Tanzanie
alors c'est un sujet intéressant qui a
occupé un peu à la cop27 là je suis
et sur lequel le regard
européen le regard africain sont assez
différents très très différents donc
c'est l'Africain au mois qui va vous
répondre quand même
l'Ouganda
elle ne produit pas
6 tonnes par habitant de gaz à effet de
serre mais 0,1
elle est dans les 10 pays du monde qui
ont produisent le moins
le Ganda a des ressources sans pétrole
c'est un pays qui a
même un niveau de richesse plus bas que
le que le nôtre Bénin
ce qu'on vient
le revenu par tête c'est 1300 euros
par an
le revenu par tête de l'Ouganda c'est
800 par an
c'est donc parmi les pays pauvres avec
des richesses minérales et des richesses
agricoles inouïe l'abbaye qui a besoin
d'enclencher son développement c'est un
pays qui à la demande de la diplomatie
américaine a renoncé récemment a acheté
aux Russes
du pétrole et du gaz et le résultat
c'est que comme il n'y a pas eu de
solidarité des pays occidentaux sont en
pénurie de carburant
ils ont une ressource
qui s'il ne faisait rien portrait leurs
émissions de zéro une tonne peut-être
pas 6 tonnes par habitant
en réalité française d'une économie
européenne déjà très décarbonée par
rapport aux autres c'est pas des
chiffres américains
en exploitant cette ressource
dans un pays où 70% des gens n'ont pas
l'électricité
vous savez ne pas avoir l'électricité
pas de chaîne de froid perte ses
récoltes accoucher à la torche
électrique ne pas pouvoir faire ses
devoirs après 18h coucher du soleil ne
pas avoir de respirateur dans les
hôpitaux vous savez pas avoir
l'électricité franchement c'est pas
simple c'est la majorité de la
population
les besoins essentiels en Afrique ne
sont pas du tout du tout alors qu'on est
extrêmement vertueux du point de vue de
la carbonation sont pas du tout
satisfaits là il s'agit des satisfaire
quand il y aura une raffinerie
transamie où on nous Ganda on ne sera
pas en pénurie sur ce qui est la
principale contrainte d'importation qui
n'est pas l'alimentation c'est les
produits pétroliers
est-ce que des pays qui
émettent 60 fois moins
de gaz effet de serre
au fond doivent renoncer à leur
ressources
alors qu'ils ont ce niveau de revenus
une question que je vous pose mais que
tous les africains présents Macky Sall
président exercice de l'Union africaine
est très clair dessus une question de
justice
absolument de base la justice est
importante en matière climatique mais
surtout en fait on ne va pas faire ce
qu'on fait les Chinois et ce qu'on fait
les Européens et ce qu'on fait les
Américains c'est ça qui si vous voulez
être un tout petit peu en dynamique il
faut être un peu en dynamique
on va pas faire de la transition
énergique énergétique sale on a aucune
raison de le faire imaginez que nous
prenions un comportement européen un
comportement modèle Europe à la
française pour ne pas parler de prendre
un comportement chinois c'est-à-dire à
une composante d'énergie par unité de
PIB record
comprenant si on faisait ça le monde
serait totalement invivable donc on ne
va pas faire ça on va faire de
l'agroforesterie on va faire du
renouvelable on va avoir un mix qu'on
peut avoir nous sommes les plus
rentables en solaire nous sommes les
plus rentables en biomasse ce n'est plus
rentables en hydraulique il n'y a pas de
comparaison avec les autres continents
par conséquent le mix énergétique dans
une Afrique je vous préviens où tout le
monde aura l'électricité dans 10 ans
c'est pas la peine de faire des sites
sur le thème je vais t'empêcher d'avoir
de l'électricité parce que c'est nous
qui mourons c'est
de très bonne fois mais l'Afrique aura
de l'électricité dans 10 ans il se
trouve que le pays qui avec le Danemark
est le plus avancé dans le mix en
renouvelable au monde c'est le Maroc
et évidemment qu'on va faire comme le
Maroc il y a aucune raison qu'on se
comporte comme ce sont comportés les
pays qui se comportaient dans un autre
système de contraintes et dans un
n'avons pas un capitalisme effréné qui
va tout faire pour ne rien faire en
termes de compensation en termes de
reforestation en termes d'utilisation du
renouvelable il y a aucune raison qu'on
fasse comme vous enfin je dis vous
en particulier non mais il faut quand
même que l'excédent comprenne
mais l'Occident va est-ce que l'Occident
va comprendre parce que non mais c'est
pas très grave parce qu'en fait on va le
faire tout seul il faut quand même que
il faut quand même que je vous le dise
qu'on va le faire tout seul évidemment
qu'on a besoin d'opérateurs ici un
pétrolier etc et de technologie mais de
faire que ça ne dit que ça ne
déstabilise pas vous parler des planètes
ça fait des décennies qu'on demande des
ressources pour
au fond tirer le maximum
de certificat carbone de nos forêts il y
a aucune réponse ce qui s'est
charmer le chèque on le commande jamais
comme ça mais ce qui est intéressant à
chaque échec c'est que on a beaucoup
parlé de l'Afrique sous l'angle des
dommages qu'on lui cause alors qu'elle
n'est en rien dans les causes mais il se
trouve que elle elle est l'une des plus
vulnérables avec le moins de
responsabilités et les pays responsables
donc on a beaucoup parlé d'Afrique et
simplement il s'est révélé que c'est
l'Afrique toute seule
qui va devoir le faire
merci
vous parlez de déstabilisation
vous connaissez le principe de la France
Afrique vous connaissez le principe de
déstabiliser un petit pays pour payer
une élection présidentielle parce que
derrière vous me donnez des contrats sur
6 ça ça
comment l'Afrique perçoit ça cette
corruption
et quelles sont les mesures proactives
pour éviter ça
la corruption
mais il a déstabilisation par des
puissances extérieures
mais
si vous voulez on n'est pas on est là il
y a des corruption
mais je crains que ce soit un phénomène
assez universel
vous me posez la question comme si je
venais d'ailleurs dans le système
solaire c'est à dire
les populations africaines n'aurait pas
de valeur
comment on regarde la corruption avec un
regard des valeurs comment vous prévenez
comment va se prémunir de la corruption
nous avons des forces spirituelles nous
avons des forces morales nous avons des
forces politiques tout le monde n'est
pas partisan des dictatures corrompus ou
des régimes de narcotrafic
l'aspiration à l'intégrité est une
valeur universellement pratiquée en
Afrique donc le regard sur la corruption
il y a aucun doute
cela étant on est
dans une situation où la corruption est
plus facile dans ce stand de pays que
notre pays que dans d'autres si vous
êtes dans des systèmes où la règle de
drones s'applique pas vous avez pas de
liberté de la presse vous n'avez pas de
liberté et de pouvoir de la justice vous
êtes évidemment il y a des pays qui
cumulent ces choses vous êtes évidemment
dans une situation où la corruption peut
prospérer malgré le mal qu'elle fait aux
populations qui en sont les premières
victimes et peut paralyser les décisions
et vraiment gangrener très très
fortement
ça va de soi c'est évidemment moins le
cas là où les responsables politiques
sont obligés de rendre des comptes ils
sont soumis à des élections donc la
partie plus démocratique où la règle de
droit est mieux
développer et évidemment
moins corrompu que moins infectés de
corruption que que les autres parties
mais c'est un phénomène universel
maintenant moi dans mon dans mon
expérience professionnelle j'ai voyagé
beaucoup cette manière c'est à dire que
Monsieur un peu occupé d'industrie mais
c'était une multinationale donc j'ai vu
beaucoup de pays je suis occupé de
banque d'affaires mais c'était une
banque d'affaires très internationale
j'ai travaillé en Grande-Bretagne comme
industriel et comme financier j'avais
été comme étudiant enfin j'ai vu
quelques pays
écoutez je vais en citer aucun parce que
j'ai aucune raison d'être blessant mais
si je pense
à Lorient lointain
un des grandes puissances
est-ce que j'ai à qui la pression par
mon expérience que c'était des pays
exemples de corruption pas une minute
quand je pense alors à l'Orient proche
quand je pense à l'Orient proche
je me demande mais il y a des grands
marchés
marché de défense et marché
d'infrastructures
est-ce qu'ils sont exemples de
corruption
quand je parcourais un grand pays de
l'Amérique du Nord et que
on m'expliquait un peu les marchés
d'infrastructures
d'État fédérés par État fédéré
quand je regardais le financement des
élections dont on a atteint des records
récents
avec les communautés qui faisaient
ensuite des grands des grands travaux
d'infrastructure sur les ressources
naturelles j'ai eu du mal à me
convaincre que cet exemple de correction
je pense que nous sommes des
petits-enfants de la corruption parce
que on est pauvres vous savez
franchement il vaut mieux être corrompu
n'importe où qu'en Afrique c'est plus
rentable mais chez nous c'est
intolérable parce que il y a des gens
qui vivent en dessous du seuil de survie
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
question
si j'arrive à le lire
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la dernière
coque et sur l'aide financière des pays
les plus riches sur la transition
écologique
est-ce que vous avez lu le rapport du
GIEC le GIEC dit qu'il ne faut laisser
les énergies fossiles dans le sol dans
le projet
cop0 c'est ça
quand on vous dit il faut laisser vos
ressources dans le sol qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire
et on va parler en fait réchauffement
climatique derrière on va pousser un peu
le sujet dans la prospective donc quand
il y a le
G qui vous dit vous laissez vos
hydrocarbures dans le sol
oui mais la question c'est est-ce que ça
s'applique de la même façon à tous les
pays d'une part et d'autre part au pays
qui sont à même de compenser
de compenser
ce qui va être mis
est-ce que
One Size feat soul
voilà il y a une recommandation qui
convient à tout le monde sait c'est le
prêt-à-porter de la pensée
et on va faire abstraction
du fait que on n'a pas d'électricité
pas dans les hôpitaux on nous dit mais
digitalisez-vous ce serait bien
digitaliser il faut pouvoir avoir un peu
d'électricité pour pour le téléphone et
pour pour l'ordinateur
vous savez on perd c'est un différent à
tout le monde
on perd 30 à 40% de notre production
agricole
et animal
c'est pas de chaîne de froid mais pas de
chaîne
très très clair l'Afrique orale
l'électricité et l'Afrique va utiliser
les moyens de le faire dans un mix sans
aucune comparaison avec ce qu'on fait
les prédécesseurs soyons très clair et
donc on ne laissera pas
sous prétexte que on est en train de
rouvrir des mines de charbon de lignite
etc dans les perruches on ne laissera
pas en terre mais simplement on est
conscient parce que la génération qui
vient d'africain est parfaitement
consciente puisque c'était la première
victime c'est pas la peine de lui faire
un rapport du GIEC pour lui dire tes
côtes sont érodées ta langue de Barbarie
à Saint-Louis
l'album de sable qui protège a disparu
c'est pas la peine de le pas la peine de
lire le chèque suffit d'être pécheur à
Saint-Louis du Sénégal quand on te dit
les inondations catastrophiques du Niger
pratiquement pas entendu parler
pratiquement pas elles ont la même
ampleur que les innovations
catastrophiques du de la Belgique de
l'Allemagne dans l'année
quand les inondations quand on parle
sécheresse dans le Gaden dans la Somalie
dans la Corne de l'Afrique quand
le Programme alimentaire mondial lance
un
appel au secours que personne n'entend
moi je ne vois ça à la Une absolument
pas je vois aucune ONG s'enchaîner pour
qu'on fasse quelque chose alors qu'il y
a un risque de 25 millions de morts dans
la Corne de l'Afrique pour des raisons
parfaitement identifiées les rythmes de
précipitation les effets catastrophiques
climatiques on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
tout le monde lui rapport du GIEC c'est
pas la peine de faire comme si au fond
on n'avait pas de diffusion mais on n'a
pas besoin on le vit concrètement et
c'est pas nos émissions qui sont pour
quoi que ce soit au moins au moins à la
Coop c'était clair
ce que refusait les pays
occidentaux c'est de d'admettre que
ça mérite indemnisation de ni être pour
rien et donner les principales victimes
parce que si il admet d'un point de vue
juridique c'est d'abord c'est quasi
pénal et ça va les poursuivre et ça va
conduire à des dépenses qu'on va
évidemment évaluer
de compensations de dédommagement fameux
problème loves les dédommagements que
vous ne devez et donc ils craignent que
ça coûte extrêmement cher parce qu'on a
compris je crois Charles échec c'est que
c'est l'Afrique elle-même qui va devoir
le faire en fait il va devoir faire
toute la construction de la transition
énergétique mais à la question de
laisser le charbon en terre en Allemagne
tous les Africains souscrivent
à la question de ne pas passer à un peu
plus d'émissions qui permet de sauver
des vies
mais que nous allons compenser par toute
une série d'actions que nous avons
l'espace que nous avons les ressources
pour développer
alors une question qu'on parle justice
climatique comme Macky Sall président
Sénégal prisonnier africaine ou maudit
le Premier ministre de l'Inde qui est
plus ambigu parce que lui utilisait
énormément de charbon l'Afrique du Sud
qui est une qui est construite sur une
masse de charbon
est en train d'accepter de ne plus
utiliser le charbon donc passer la crise
ukrainienne ça va être une
transformation très importante parce que
c'est le pays qui émet le plus de gaz de
serre en Afrique c'est à dire il en est
autant que la France par habitant la
France est un des pays qui en émet le
moins en Europe donc celui qui est au
sommet le plus industrialisé et qui
disait vraiment de charbon se désengager
du charbon ça c'est très légitime mais
pensez que dans mon pays où il y a 50%
de gens qui ont pas d'électricité on
n'aura pas l'électricité
pensez que le pétrole du Niger qui est
en voie d'exploitation
et le pipeline qui va à Cotonou on va
les arrêter alors
il y a eu une destruction des forêts
galeries d'Afrique de l'Ouest et ça on
peut refaire
et je vous assure on a perdu depuis
5 ans depuis 60 ans
80% des forêts qu'on appelle les forêt
galeries au long des fleuves d'Afrique
de l'Ouest pourquoi pour faire de la
production
de plantation industrielle
mais je vous assure que quand on fait
des plantations de cacao
c'est pas nous qui mangeons le chocolat
il y a une question
de chaleur ils font
et donc c'est très très peu adapté au
pays
intercropicaux donc je vous assure que
nos plantations industrielles vous savez
on a des grandes plantations des va
tout ça ça détruit les forêts primaires
mais vous savez combien on vend de
véhicules neufs en Afrique
c'est en novembre pas 22 millions comme
la Chine en même pas 24 millions comme
l'Europe on en vend un peu moins de 2
millions mais on est quand même un
milliard 4 c'est moins que le marché
français mais vous n'êtes pas un
milliard 4 nous sommes à 4 donc je vous
assure que les grandes plantations des
BA qui ont détruit les forêts primaires
c'est pas notre irresponsabilité donc
pour faire des pneus
plutôt des emballages plutôt des choses
il y a plein de choses intéressantes
avec du latex si vous voulez mais ne pas
les grands consommateurs donc faire un
tout petit peu attention si vous pensez
que l'Afrique va adhérer à l'idée vous
n'avez plus le droit d'utiliser vos
ressources non ce à quoi l'Afrique
adhère c'est si on peut créer les moyens
de compenser tout cela et d'avoir
quelque chose qui est équilibré en
croissance et en création d'emplois on
va le faire en fait
et du coup sur les dépays riches dans la
transition proposée à la coop
qu'est-ce que je voulais que
l'aide publique au développement on
n'ose plus l'appeler comme ça
pour une raison simple c'est que c'est
pas sûr que ça soit de l'aide parce que
c'est souvent de la dette souvent du
crédit
et c'est pas sûr que ça développe
donc faire très attention à ça
aujourd'hui on parle de partenariat on
essaye d'éviter le mot aide publique au
développement donc
non on va être obligé de compter sur nos
propres ressources et c'est déjà le cas
si vous voulez connaissez les grands
chiffres l'Afrique reçoit bonhomme
allant entre 60 et 70 milliards de
dollars de d'aide publique au
développement
elle reçoit 20 30% de plus de remise
d'épargne de ces migrants
aujourd'hui
parlons les flux des migrants sont
beaucoup plus importants que les flux
d'être public
on va parler des questions migration
donc ça va en fait on va s'occuper de
nous-même et vous allez nous laisser
crever mais pas du tout pour l'instant
vous ne donnez aucun signe de faiblesse
votre espérance de vie sauvée en 2020 a
l'air de continuer à progresser vous
savez à quelle espérance de vie
en 1960 à la remise des insignes de la
souveraineté aux République d'Afrique de
l'Ouest ça veut dire qu'il était
l'espérance de vie à la naissance d'un
pays comme le Mali le Burkina combien 35
37 28
28 c'est l'espérance de vie
de la France de 1760 mais nous c'est
notre réalité des années 60 mais 1960
pas 1760 aujourd'hui si vous voulez on
est quand même plutôt à 61 ans
et aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui on gagne un an par an
c'est à dire qu'en fait notre
développement nous a jamais été octroyés
l'éducation
UPT c'est-à-dire à peu près au niveau
1760 aujourd'hui tu voulais l'Afrique
est dans une démarche complètement
endogène vous pouvez pas imaginer quand
vous dites vous apportez la civilisation
c'est sarcastique
chez Jules Ferry c'était pas au premier
c'était vraiment au premier degré
climatique
l'élévation de la température de la
terre là on est bien on est au dessus du
degré 5
si on monte à 3 degrés la fric ça va
ressembler à quoi
non mais tout le monde va ressembler à
quelque chose c'est un vraisemblable
ça va être terrible ok tout le monde
parce que à ce genre de niveau vous
allez avoir des chocs incroyables
d'avoir des inversions du Goldstream
vous allez avoir des climats sibériens
dans des régions aujourd'hui tempérées
vous allez voir des phénomènes ces
phénomènes ne se produiront pas parce
que parce qu'il va y avoir une
mobilisation gigantesque ne serait-ce
que parce que les tous premiers
prodromes de cette évolution
comment ça frapper des opinions
publiques des pays des pays riches mais
c'est assez neuf mais ça c'est intenable
donc la question c'est pas à quoi
ressemblera l'Afrique c'est quel est le
devenir de l'humanité sur la planète
planète se portera probablement de façon
très
normale
sans les êtres humains mais donc non si
vous laissez pas c'est vraiment le
problème de tous c'est le problème de
tous c'est pas mal qu'on commence à
écouter l'Afrique puisque pour l'instant
c'est quand même le seul puis carbone
qu'on puisse encore préserver encore que
le Brésil va peut-être
le gestionnaire de forêt amazonienne
vont peut-être
prêt bolsonaro avoir des comportements
différents et que l'Indonésie vous avez
vu qui a été le plus des pays les plus
actifs à déforester pour faire des
plantations industrielles et est en voie
de récupération de reforestation non
négligeable donc oui
l'Afrique fera partie
des solutions pour l'instant ce sont les
pays les plus développés qui sont les
problèmes nous ne sommes pas le problème
mais maintenant comment ça penser à
l'Afrique en terme de solutions mais
très peu très peu dans mon métier avec
une équipe de grand talent on essaye de
faire venir
des capitaux
pour valoriser pour développer cette
capacité de depuis carbone il faut
combien
écouter pas beaucoup d'argent on a
demandé 100 milliards qui ont été actés
à Glasgow et évidemment pas du tout
respecté pas du tout
100 milliards vous avez en tête que le
monde produit de richesse 80
000 milliards par an
pour que des capitaux privés
ce qui est capitaux privés disponible
sur les spams l'épargne disponible du
monde c'est un multiple de la production
de chaque année
l'épargne constituée dans le monde c'est
pas 80000 milliards ça c'est la
production annuelle c'est 4 fois ça
l'épargne du monde j'en connais beaucoup
beaucoup de ressources je peux mais ils
ont peur du risque moi je consacrerai ce
que l'Occident est prêt à mettre à
garantir
contre des risques à mon avis très
largement imaginaire des capitaux privés
parce que c'est les capitaux privés
c'est l'épargne qui doit venir et
notamment en Afrique sur tout ce qu'on
peut faire pour
accélérer augmenter encore ce rôle de
puis carbone du continent j'ouvre une
parenthèse est-ce que l'épargne c'est de
la calorie stockée
de la calories stocker
ça dépend quand vous l'employez si vous
utilisez votre épargne
à faire des investissements à très fort
contenu de carbone
vous êtes sur la dépanne est un
instrument du réchauffement climatique
puissant si vous utilisez cet épargne
à refaire rester à combiner ça avec de
l'agriculture en complantation et à
développer des technologies qui
économisent du carbone et un mix
énergétique qui utilise du redoublable
votre épargne est un instrument de
décarbonation ça dépend ce que vous en
faites notre départ revenons un peu sur
la géopolitique là on voit les Chinois
les Russes les Américains bon les
Français se terminaient
frillez à prendre le contrôle des
opinions publiques à faire des
opérations déstabilisation
à envoyer des mercenaires à gauche à
droite
la perception africaine elle en est où
pourquoi les Chinois arrivent à
s'implanter comme ça bon même si ça
commence à punir un peu
pourquoi les russes arrivent à
déstabiliser les pays
à s'accaparer d'opinion publique ou à
faire semblant de s'accaparer l'opinion
publique pourquoi
mais pourquoi ça rentre comme dans du
beurre
j'adore votre question je la trouve
tellement française merci
m'écoutez l'Afrique je vais prendre une
mauvaise nouvelle
est indépendante
une mauvaise nouvelle l'Afrique et le
seul continent en excédant sur la Chine
ok alors commercial
les États-Unis encore un peu plus grands
donc je retourne la question comment ça
se fait que ce soit aussi facile
d'acheter le port du Piret comment ça se
fait que vous ayez un déficit commercial
par l'Afrique en longue période et le
seul continent en excédent sur la Chine
parce que c'est l'usine du monde et que
nous on produit les matières premières
du monde donc évidemment donc je vous
retrouve la question et par ailleurs
est-ce qu'il aurait fallu maintenir
l'exclusif coloniale c'est-à-dire vous
êtes canon vous êtes client il faut
acheter des produits britanniques vous
êtes sénégalais vous êtes de Béninois
faut acheter des produits français vous
êtes angolais il faut vous fournir au
Portugal ok exclusive colonial ça a
fonctionné très très bien
la Chine il se trouve que c'est le
premier exportateur du monde
également le premier importateur du
monde premier
mais c'est le premier c'est tout le
monde c'est le premier si vous prenez le
roseau dans son ensemble sont partenaire
principal c'est évidemment la Chine pas
du tout les États-Unis et ces trois
grandes économies c'est trois plus
grands au monde bon
donc évidemment que l'Afrique est un
marché pour la Chine et les compétitives
énormément de domaines et nous elle nous
donne l'immense avantage de la
concurrence
et notamment dans l'investissement dans
la réalisation d'infrastructures si vous
payez deux fois plus cher votre barrage
si vous avez un seul fournisseur de
barrage nous avons des appels d'offres
signes hydro
gagne beaucoup de fabrication de barrage
mais Vinci
il parvient et il s'améliore et baisse
ses coûts etc donc bah si il n'est pas
du tout sorti de de la lutte
concurrentielle mais nous nous avons des
avantages de qualité prix à faire jouer
la concurrence vous avez des grandes
puissances émergentes comme la Turquie
par exemple qui réalise aussi beaucoup
d'infrastructures qui sont excellentes
en construction mais l'Egypte en Afrique
est de plus en plus exportatrice ce
service de
construction etc nous avons comme tout
le monde besoin de mettre en concurrence
pour avoir de la qualité et du prix
voilà et en revanche comme nous sommes
des exportateurs importants vers la
Chine des matières premières dont on a
besoin pour vous vendre les produits
on est un excédent sur la Chine
donc c'est pas en hype d'être pas comme
ça
vous allez me dire c'est quand même
dommage qu'il soit aussi important dans
tel port lequel mais bon
voilà il faut le dire assez vite parce
que les grands exports les grands
l'opérateurs de port c'est plutôt
mercure danoises plutôt CMA CGM le
français plutôt MSC little Suisse plutôt
que Costco le chinois mais bon vous
pouvez me dire ça
enfin le Piré c'est pas en Afrique
Sri Lanka non plus là où vous avez eu
des investissements très très important
de l'échine dans des infrastructures
décisives déterminantes et qu'en Afrique
donc faire un tout petit peu attention
la Russie le Mali Wagner
vous allez voir quelques centaines de
mercenaires dans un pays d'un million de
cent mille kilomètres carrés qui va donc
tenter de stabiliser une situation
militaire à cette échelle
un pays de 20 millions d'habitants
c'est déjà difficile de conquérir
l'Ukraine à 150000 dont un contingent
Wagner sur 600 000 km². mais elle aura
500 dont on paye d'ailleurs pas la seule
tous les mois il se met en grève
même avec des méthodes barbares prouvées
avec un échec total embarqué c'est les
Rwandais qui sont venus au secours du
Mozambique l'armée rwandaise
Wagner est en reparti par Marie prouvé
également en Centrafrique bon
vous avez une garde prétorienne
qui est faite pour garder au pouvoir
ceux qui l'ont pris mais contrôler le
Mali à quelques centaines de
mercenaires je suis pas sûr que ce soit
une relation de toutes les règles de
droit internationale je suis pas sûr que
ce soit une percée qui va durablement
installer une influence russe évidemment
qu'il y a des opérations minières au
Mali qui intéresse la Russie et
notamment le propriétaire de la Légion
Wagner évidemment mais aucune de ces
mines des Françaises
canadiennes sud-africaine
il y a pas une mine française au Mali
mais il y a et donc les gens que les
Russes sont expropriés s'il reste
remplacés au Mali sont pas les Français
regardez les chiffres si vous voulez on
parle d'un engagement financier zéro
très très faible d'un investissement
infrastructure Émile
quasi zéro
et de quelques centaines de mercenaires
avec un effet qui est extraordinaire sur
le plan de la communication de
l'influence des fake news ça c'est
franchement un grand grand chef-d'oeuvre
nos amis iraniens et nos amis turcs nous
y avait préparé depuis une quinzaine
d'années mais alors là franchement c'est
beaucoup beaucoup mieux fait par la par
la Russie et ça imprime assez peu nos
opinions publiques mais c'est un effet
énorme sur les opinions occidentales
c'est-à-dire que en réalité c'est
évidemment tourné ces influences
tourner vers l'opinion française pliant
allemand de pignons pourquoi et pas pour
nous pourquoi mais parce que il faut
créer le sentiment que le rejet de
l'Europe est en train et de la France
parmi les Européens enfin ils sont
attaqués au contingent danois ils sont
aux Allemands etc il faut faire il faut
créer dans l'opinion européenne l'idée
que le sentiment anti-européen
antioxydantal a désormais inondé
inondé l'Afrique c'est un ensemble de de
fake news parce que c'est pas du tout le
sentiment majoritaire mais c'est le
sentiment d'une minorité active très
très bien relayée par
au fond des activités d'influence qui
sont puissantes mais regardez ce que la
Russie projette vraiment en Afrique en
termes d'hommes de techniciens en termes
même de mercenaires d'ailleurs en nombre
mais mais en terme de capitaux en termes
de crédit et vous verrez que c'est quand
même très très peu de choses alors
peut-être qu'il va y avoir des choses
intéressantes parce que vous savez qu'il
y a une coopération entre EDF
et recettes homme
pour faire des mini centrales nucléaires
quand on a bien besoin en Afrique et
c'était le produit le plus attractif de
la panoplie de ce que proposait la
Russie guerre
en coopération avec avec une fois la
paix revenue ce serait intéressant parce
que c'est petit réacteurs
d'électricité des carbonée ça se
pourrait être intéressant surtout si la
coopération continue avec EDF surtout si
l'uranium vient toujours d'Afrique
[Musique]
une menace
terroriste
croissante donc il faut complètement
changer les doctrines d'engagement
il faut agir de façon beaucoup plus
solidaire il y a quelque chose s'appelle
l'initiative d'Accra
où étaient les gens européens de l'Union
européenne récemment
en fait il y a deux jours
en fait tous les pays d'Afrique de
l'Ouest sont en train de de
rendre commun leurs efforts contre le
terrorisme donc oui il y a une menace
terroriste il y a pas de doute
après si vous voulez pour l'instant
c'est de la science-fiction le nucléaire
le nucléaire civil en Afrique pour
l'instant il y a une centrale en Afrique
du Sud pour l'instant c'est de la
science-fiction ça va ça peut devenir
réalité il y a d'autres travaux
Monsieur Bill Gates investit énormément
sur la même recherche
mais avec une dimension supérieure qui
est de ne pas dégager de déchets à
recycler ça c'est un c'est vraiment très
important comme comme recherche donc il
va y avoir sur une énergie nucléaire
plus propre sans recyclage peut-être des
avancées dans les 10 ans et ça sera
important pour le pour la décarbonation
mais bon c'est un peu une boutade
puisque pour vous rappeler qu'il y a des
coopérations franco-russes parfois un
peu inattendu dans l'espace
les migrants
les zodiaques les embarcations de
fortune les ce qui se passe en Libye
quelle est la perfection quelle est la
perception sur le continent alors on dit
toujours que la majeure partie des flux
migratoires se passe à l'intérieur du
continent
il y a eu combien de millions de morts
africains en Méditerranée toujours trop
des millions
centaines de milliers de morts
oui c'est probable si vous prenez sur un
talon
comment c'est perçu comment s'est perçu
les camps de rétention
administratives les camps de migrants à
Lampedusa et des choses comme ça
commencez perçu
ces images qui en Europe choquent des
échelles avec 2000 gars qui passent
pourquoi il y a ces phénomènes là
il y a beaucoup de perception
très très à vif
parce que là encore un peu comme tout à
l'heure sur nos ressources naturelles et
nos hydrocarbures entre le regard
européen et le regard français on se
croise plus
je crois plus
les quantums les nombres de migrants qui
sont venus créer des sujets majeurs de
politique intérieure en Europe ne sont
pas africains soyons clairs c'est
le mouvement de la guerre du
Proche-Orient c'est les Syriens vous
avez en tête que il y a un accord avec
la Turquie pour en immobiliser de
millions et vous êtes en tête que dans
le million et demi qui est arrivé c'est
pas du tout de l'Africains c'est lié la
situation syrienne mais la translation
immédiate c'est
l'Afrique il faut absolument stabiliser
l'Afrique la vague qui a posé des
problèmes jusque en Allemagne ou qui
s'était complètement ouvertes qui en a
posé en Suède qui elle est pas africaine
les images de lampe 12 à sont africaines
parce que ne vous mets pas les images de
Lesbos
donc faire un tout petit peu attention
au vrai compteur
il est très asiatique parce que la Syrie
la Turquie c'est en Afrique alors oui il
y a des guerres il y a le Darfour et il
y a la Libye etc qui sont des facteurs
très importants
les flux liés à une migration de
recherche du travail
ne sont pas des flux de la misère ce ne
sont pas du tout les plus miséreux qui
migrent ce sont les plus jeunes et plus
courageux souvent les mieux formés
ça n'existe pas la migration de la
misère c'est pas vrai
les Marocains qui passent c'est la
misère pardon les Marocains les jeunes
marocains mais c'est pas la misère c'est
simulé ce n'est pas
ce ne sont pas les gens n'ont pas les
moyens ni de payer les passeurs ni
d'imaginer ni de conceptualiser ni les
réseaux de famille
en Europe qui sont les plus misérables
dans nos pays carencés étaient tenus sur
leur terre c'est une population jeune et
entreprenante donc faut arrêter avec
la cette idée ce pathos de la migration
de la misère et en plus il y a quelque
chose qui devrait un peu affoler les
gens qui ont des solutions très simples
développer l'Afrique comme ça il reste
son chez eux
c'est pas très scientifique c'est
vraiment très rudimentaire
les flux migratoires sont strictement
corrélés au développement alors plus on
se développera plus il y aura de flux
migratoires et qui sont pas des flux de
fuite
3e perception nos médecins nos
ingénieurs nos informaticiens sont
dragués
vers l'Europe systématiquement avec des
offres parler
les Marocains qui passent dans le
détroit d'Algésiras c'est quand même
bien la misère pas du tout en nombre
quel est le problème du Maroc c'est que
en vous offrant une carte de résidence
de 10 ans ou une nationalité Schengen on
recrute massivement les ingénieurs
marocains les médecins marocains les
infirmières marocaines etc c'est ça la
réalité la moitié de notre promotion de
l'école paramédicale de Parakou au nord
du Bénin par en Europe parce qu'on n'est
pas l'infirmier mais c'est pas vous qui
n'est pas d'infirmière ou pas de médecin
l'OMS dit qu'il en manque 12 millions de
médecins dans le monde
il y a pas que des déserts médicaux
qu'en France donc il y a une drainage
considérable
je vous assure que nous
les Béninois
qui viennent en France
ce sont des gens qualifiés ce sont
souvent des gens diplômés
c'est absolument pas ce que vous avez en
tête comme image habituelle quatrième
perception
l'Europe est parfaitement capable de
supporter
et dans tous les sens du mot supporter
d'accepter de soutenir des migrants en
masse
à condition qu'il soit blond
qui dit les yeux bleus et qui soit
à peu près deux heures d'avion de chez
vous
l'entrée c'est absolument extraordinaire
moi je parlais avec un maire
de l'Essonne
qui dit on est absolument ravis ce qu'on
a reçu beaucoup d'Ukrainiens parce que
on a trouvé des gens pour le renseigner
en escrainien pour aider à faire qui
rattrape très très vite à l'école
naturellement ils ont tous les droits
sociaux naturellement on a tous logés en
fait un tout petit peu attention parce
que les étudiants africains en Ukraine
on la refusé à tous de sortir du crâne
pour aller continuer leurs études c'est
parce que c'était dingue parce que vous
êtes en train de contourner il y a eu
une grève très honorable à la Sorbonne
printemps dernier des étudiants qui
n'acceptaient pas la décision du recteur
de Paris on inscrira pas à l'université
des gens qui étaient à l'université de
Kiev ou de Juifs
c'était africain et que c'est une espèce
de ruse pour obtenir ce qui n'aurait pas
obtenu en venant directement de leur
pays africain
et les étudiants se sont mis en grève
heureusement quand même quelqu'un quelle
belle réaction éthique ça c'est un
traumatisme énorme c'est-à-dire à vous
les avez en plus vous avez bastonné etc
à la frontière la police polonaise a été
abominable mais rappelez-vous les
incidents entre polonais biélorus quand
Vladimir Poutine avait eu la bonne idée
d'aller nous recruter des migrants pour
les faire rentrer en Pologne par la
Biélorussie et que il y avait des
exections des polices des deux côtés
donc on a eu droit à ça pour les pour
les étudiants
africains en Ukraine
et c'est très général
l'Afrique serait ravie de mon avis on a
on a reçu un certain nombre
reçoit des Ukrainiens c'est pas le sujet
on a le sens de l'hospitalité
c'est de voir le traitement qui était
fait dans ces circonstances oui l'Europe
est capable de façon qui ne la
déstabilise pas de recevoir des familles
chrétiennes et tout le monde tout le
monde est ravi de cet accueil aux
familles chrétiens
ukrainienne mais ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire c'est les 10 000 étudiants faire
sortir du crâne et s'inscrire dans
l'université
et là les gens se sont dit c'est pas
simplement la crainte d'une
déstabilisation c'est pas
c'est fondamentalement du racisme et ça
ça porte un coup valeur occidentale non
négligeable donc les sentiments sont
très très mêlés sur l'immigration mais
ce qui fait mal si vous voulez
c'est de prendre conscience de façon
dont on est traité par différence avec
ce qui peut se faire
dans le monde manifestement il vaut
mieux être craignant que syrien il vaut
mieux être syrien que guinéen
un peu la hiérarchie claire
c'est un peu troublant
voilà si vous laissez ce qu'on en parle
et au fait que le brain drain
continue personne n'en parle
l'aspiration des cerveaux
oui
je vais faire de la migration choisie
mais je vais vraiment aller recruter
vous savez dans les années 60 on avait
des bureaux de recrutement dans le bled
comme on disait dans le Maghreb pour les
usines françaises en pleine surchauffe
on est allés on est allés recruter
chercher les gens qui n'étaient pas du
tout volontaires en Maroc Tunisie en
Algérie avec des bureaux de recrutement
c'est la même chose aujourd'hui moi
j'aimerais bien qu'une émission
d'investigation
plutôt que d'aller se demander ah oui
mais en Ouganda si vous faites du
pétrole est-ce que c'est la classe
politique qui va récupérer la rente moi
j'aimerais bien qui des émissions
d'investigation
à dire combien vous a proposé et quelle
nationalité Schengen est-ce que c'est
Portugal est-ce que c'est Espagne chez
France pour que vous qui êtes ophtalmo
là des qui démarrait et on a besoin
d'ophtalmo de façon incroyable au Bénin
vous allez vous installer plutôt
Angoulême
et l'ingénieur et l'informaticien qui
sort de l'école centrale de Casablanca
et pour qu'il aille travailler à
Amsterdam mais combien et quels
instrument et après on en reparlera de
arrêtons nous ne pouvons pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde mais si vous
laissez pas du tout ça qu'on fait en ce
moment vous êtes en train de prélever
une partie de la richesse du monde donc
les sentiments sont comme vous voyez
très mêlés très à vif
et alors ne parlons pas de la Comédie
des visas qui est quand même
relativement
insupportable donc si vous voulez
c'est pas un terrain qui rapproche
beaucoup les peuples quand on est
métisse on est quand même c'est quand
même difficile d'être métisse de nos
jours il y a du racisme en Afrique sur
les Métis à votre avis à mort non
beaucoup
il y a du racisme des métis
une société qui admet l'altérité
de culture
de pratique sociale de code etc non donc
évidemment est-ce que vous connaissez
des sociétés qui au moment où elles
envahissent d'autres espaces et quels
endocrines ou qu'elle les évangélistes
quelle que soit la religion du livre
concerné qui ne sont pas en train de
produire en même temps un discours de
l'infériorité de celui qu'on va
soumettre ce que ça existe
est-ce que c'est possible d'arabiser
est-ce que c'est possible d'être d'avoir
un esclavage
sur un clivage de la couleur de peau et
d'être exempt de racisme est-ce que
c'est possible
d'avoir une variété de de langues de
couture
hétérogène et ne pas se faire une
doctrine du racisme non ça n'existe pas
les sociétés exemptes de
racisme donc nous avons nous avons nos
clivages
ce qui moi me frappe c'est que
l'Afrique a eu quand même des ennemis
communs
S et elle s'est affranchir de certains
de ses ennemis
et elle a fini par prendre au moins une
indépendance
institutionnelle peut-être petit à petit
il indépendance économique
et ça ça crée quand même
des liens des liens forts
moi je suis un métisse si vous me
demandez où j'ai ressenti le plus
entre mon école primaire
et au fond le pays de Savalou c'est pas
le même c'est-à-dire
j'étais insulté mon enfance en plus ma
mère était d'origine italienne et ça à
l'époque où il pensait considérés
également qu'il était raisonnable de
haïr et de flétrir les Portugais les
Espagnols les Italiens les Polonais etc
donc c'était une période des années 60
une période un peu compliqué si vous
voulez donc oui je m'en suis jamais je
n'ai jamais attribué ça aux Français à
la France attribuable dans la cour de
récréation qui me traitait de sale Niro
et j'ai pris l'habitude de prendre les
insultes pour des choses vraiment très
secondaires et les attaques et les
calomnies ce qui est très très utile si
vous faites de la politique quand vous
êtes plus grand si vous voulez mais en
Afrique c'était pas pareil
c'était c'est l'enfant blanc de la
famille et les enfants blancs c'est
formidable ensemble ça parle tout le
temps normalement ça se tait et puis ça
demande toujours pourquoi il y a un mot
chez les enfants blancs c'est incroyable
il demande toujours pourquoi et ça crée
une émotion et un plaisir inouï à toute
ma famille mais c'était quand même
l'enfant blanc
est-ce que vous voulez parler d'un sujet
qu'on n'a pas abordé
qui suivent votre votre travail et
qu'est-ce qui vous disent en général
c'est une question ça oui
Sénégal le Burkina Faso le Bénin le
Maroc la Côte d'Ivoire
et là ce qu'ils sont des demandes
particulières alors
on leur dit surtout
inspirez-vous mais ne copiez pas adapté
ou sur place
oui oui vous faites bien de le dire mais
c'est évident oui mais pour eux on
adapte tout il faut non mais ils sont
pas tous ça adaptés
dans la ceinture méditerranéenne côté
Maghreb il copie où ils veulent copier
même les questions les questions du
début de fin il copie voilà expliquer ça
sert à rien de nous copier améliorer
ça répond à votre question
non mais ce qui se trouve que vous
traitez suffisamment des problèmes qu'il
est touche le plus je n'ai pas compris
est-ce que vous trouvez
dans leur réaction
parce qu'en fait vous répondez à leurs
besoins en fait on a les mêmes problèmes
du mois
la jeunesse française européenne et la
jeunesse africaine
en fait on a les mêmes problèmes
enfin vraiment c'est dingue on se
retrouve là-dessus
assez différente ouais mais autant aller
vers la même j'ai l'impression
est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que vous
voulez aborder autre qu'on n'a pas
développé que vous souhaiteriez
développer
non parce que je crois qu'en filigrane
traverse toutes vos questions peut-être
moins sur l'histoire monétaire
américaine si vous voulez plusieurs ça
et franchement c'est rare c'est rare
qu'on est
non
c'est quoi je travaille c'est un moment
où je devrais être à la retraite bien ça
serment et je continue à essayer de
travailler c'est que je trouve que ce
continent
fait partie
de ces espaces qui ont vraiment changé à
une vitesse extraordinaire sont en train
de changer et dans la partie où nous en
avons parlé je crois que ça se
ressentait que je pense que
les forces de ce pays sont endogènes
sont très très et de ce continent sont
endogènes et et extraordinairement
créatrice et innovatrice on n'a pas
parlé d'art mais
dans ma famille on a décidé de faire des
choses notamment à chaque fois voilà
fondation dédiée aux créations
contemporaines c'est une excellente
métaphore de ce qui est l'Afrique
d'aujourd'hui en revanche les problèmes
que vous m'avez soumis auparavant qui
était plutôt alors la dette c'était
froyable alors on pourrait faire un choc
volcaire avec 15% de taux d'intérêt
etc c'est votre façon de reformuler
j'essaie de vous dire 8 ans de pathos
tout ça est quand même le quoiqu'il en
coûte il faut absolument arrêter c'est
le FMI qu'il a dit oui
c'est moi qui le redis il est perçu
comme ça et là-dessus si vous voulez ce
que j'essayais de dire c'est
ne nous accablons pas de problème
technique et financiers parce qu'on est
soumet les problèmes financiers j'ai pas
eux de nous soumettre et ça aussi c'est
une leçon que moi j'ai beaucoup apprise
plutôt en Europe parce que ma carrière
professionnelle a beaucoup été en Europe
mais qui vaut vraiment pour l'Afrique
donc il y a pas de pathos
franchement les crises économiques
heureusement on sait les rampe un peu
plus courte que dans le passé un tout
petit peu plus espacés parce qu'elle se
crée beaucoup de souffrance
mais voilà je pense que
tout ça techniquement ça se domine il
faut trois bouquins et un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
Pascal Blanchard réécrit l'histoire
coloniale il vient de sortir avec toute
une série de chercheurs une histoire de
la colonisation
je pense que c'est c'est intéressant
avec notamment des choses sur
très très utile pour le comprendre le
monde d'aujourd'hui la colonisation par
l'image
par [__] par par la monstration
des populations au Jardin
d'Acclimatation comment on vit dans les
cases etc par l'image par au fond les
fake news de l'époque et et l'influence
le lobby coloniale je pense c'est
intéressant tout le travail de Pascal
Blanchard et de son groupe de travail
l'achat ça je pense que c'est c'est une
bonne une bonne lecture pour les gens
qui s'inquiètent un peu pour l'Occident
qui aime bien regarder l'Occident d'un
peu loin
de qui sort Marwa
béni
quelque chose qui
en anglais c'était
has the West lost it
et
en français je crois que la traduction
du livre qui est paru plus récemment il
y a un an ça doit être comment le
comment le l'ouest de l'Occident a perdu
la partie vision par
Nadau chinois citoyen de Singapour
diplomate Singapour patron du plus grand
signe Tang des géopolitique d'Asie du
Sud-Est probablement
extraordinairement
critique sur le modèle
occidental et sa capacité de générer de
la prospérité de la croissance etc ça
c'est pour les gens qui veulent se faire
un tout petit peu peur ou bien ce
saisir
pendant qu'il est temps sur ce que
l'Occident à condition de se regarder
un tout petit pas avec de la avec
l'humilité un peu de modestie pensant
que c'est pas les seuls modèles
possibles et voilà
même si le modèle social européen
et social-démocrate et très très
importante et puis parce que j'aime bien
Terra Nova sinon je
l'administration tu es en novembre parce
que j'aime bien donc j'aime bien Thierry
pêche que j'aime bien Pascal Campin et
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps de parler
énormément de réchauffement climatique
il faut revenir tout ce que Terra Nova
publie notamment sur les signatures de
Pascal Camphin
qui est le président français de la
commission chargée de l'environnement de
l'écologie au Parlement européen où se
passe énormément de choses tout ce qu'il
écrit et notamment chez Terra Nova et
notamment avec Thierry pêche sur c'est
quoi une transition juste socialement
c'est quoi une transition énergétique
propre bien maîtrisée c'est quoi les
solutions qu'est-ce qui est en train de
s'élaborer en termes de normes de en
termes de de financement avec la
révolution des dettes mutualisées
du Green compact
je pense que pour les gens qui veulent
être pas dans l'invective pas
donc plus dans la guerre sur le barbecue
et autres thèmes très très mobilisateurs
d'une partie
[Musique]
un petit peu intense de l'écologie
politique
peut-être je pense c'est une bonne
lecture le site de Terra Nova pour ça
très beau un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
non mais j'ai une génération elle est
tellement meilleure que moi que c'est
pas mais on va pas jouer je suis le
petit garçon du FMI qui dit vient
industrialiser là parce que quand même
très dû y penser c'est pas moi qui lui
dire la jeune génération je constate que
mes enfants sont quand même bien
meilleurs que moi je constate que ils
ont aucun complexe je constate qu'ils
adoptent toutes les technologies quand
je ne comprends rien donc
qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de leur dire un
conseil j'ai pas envie de leur dire
aidez-moi
merci merci à vous
[Musique]